Wir sind jetzt eigentlich bis ein Uhr vom Chaos Computer Club im Studio.
Vielleicht Frank?
Ja, vielleicht Frank und vielleicht?
Harald.
Und vielleicht Max. Und wir wollen mit euch vielleicht über ein Thema reden, je nachdem, ob ihr anruft oder nicht. Das hängt dann wieder von euch ab. Und zwar war ich, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen, erst ein bisschen skeptisch. Ich dachte so, ja mal sehen, was kommt, mal sehen, über welche Themen wir so reden könnten. Dann kamen so die ersten Vorschläge und es kristallisierte sich dann raus, dass es heute Abend um das Thema Stromverbrauch von Unterhaltungs- und IT-Elektronik gehen würde. Und ich dachte mir so, wow, drei Stunden lang über Stromverbrauch reden, mir fiel da erst nicht so viel ein. Und dann kamen aber so langsam die ersten Punkte raus und da ist mir aufgefallen, dass es eigentlich ein ziemlich spannendes Thema ist.
Wir wollen heute Abend auch nicht nur über nur den Stromverbrauch reden, sondern auch vor allem ein bisschen um den Gesamt- und diese Nebenwirkungen. Das heißt also, was für Energie, was für Rohstoffe werden bei der Produktion verbraucht. Und auch unter welchen Umständen werden diese ganzen Rechner auch hergestellt, beziehungsweise auch wieder recycelt, entsorgt hinterher.
Genau, also es geht ein bisschen so in die Richtung Energiebilanz von IT-Elektronik.
So, jetzt sind wir wieder an dem Punkt, wo ihr denkt, ah, ist doch uninteressant für mich, den Normalbürger, ist es aber wirklich nicht. Und um euch das zu beweisen, haben wir uns überlegt, wir möchten ganz einfach einsteigen. Und zwar, wenn ihr einen Rechner habt, PC hat ja mittlerweile jeder, was glaubt ihr, bzw. vielleicht wisst ihr es sogar, wie viel Strom das Ding verbraucht. Dieser kleine PC, den ihr wie oft auch immer benutzt, vielleicht lasst ihr ihn durchlaufen mit irgendeinem Donkey drauf, oder vielleicht benutzt ihr den auch ganz normal, einfach nur mal zwei Stunden am Tag oder auch nur einmal in der Woche und lasst ihn sonst stehen. Dann könnt ihr anrufen, 0371 77 97 110, dann machen wir euch mal eine kleine Rechnung auf. Vielleicht wisst ihr das ja auch ganz genau, wie viel das Ding kostet, plus die ganzen kleinen Aufladegeräte, die ihr überall liegen habt und der Kram, der sonst noch überall versteckt ist. 0331 77 97 110. So, und ich würde mal sagen, ich probiere jetzt mal eure Musik aus. Was seid ihr davon?
Du hast jetzt vergessen den CD? Nein. Vielleicht noch ganz kurz, eigentlich ist ja heute die hundertste Sendung und jetzt denken alle, wir müssen ein Riesenjubiläum machen. Hatten wir eigentlich auch geplant, um ganz ehrlich zu sein, aber es kam dann alles anders. Es war ein bisschen schwierig von den Terminen her und wir sind ja auch ein bisschen Chaos und immer nicht so richtig. Und es ist aber alles viel besser, weil wir feiern nämlich dieses Jahr auch unser zehnjähriges Jubiläum. Und wir wollen ja nicht nur ein bisschen feiern, sondern wir wollen richtig feiern. Und deswegen haben wir uns gedacht, wir planen es lieber noch mal ordentlich in Ruhe, als dass wir das für diesen Termin geplant haben. Ihr habt ja auch in den letzten Monaten gemerkt, es gab immer wieder Terminverschiebungen. Chaosradio war nicht am letzten Mittwoch, sondern irgendwie plötzlich mittendrin. Und es war alles irgendwie ganz anders und kompliziert. Das hat auch was ein bisschen mit den Terminen hier zu tun. Wir lassen uns aber von nicht irritieren. Wir werden dieses Jahr feiern, das ist versprochen, und zwar ganz groß. Nicht heute, aber auf jeden Fall innerhalb der nächsten Monate.
Super, so. Und jetzt lege ich deine CD auch nochmal richtig ein, damit ihr auch kommt.
Mit der Schrift nach oben.
Ja, habe ich gemacht. Die sind halt auf beiden Seiten silber, und ich meine, was erwartest du? Ja, also so ein bisschen nerdy muss ich mich auch benehmen können. So, habt ihr Lust?
Musik?
Ja, kommt.
Prima.
Ja, dachte ich erst.
Bei drei.
Ach komm drauf, wir müssen mal anzählen.
Wir reden direkt mit André.
Hier funktioniert aber auch gar nichts im Studio. Mein Kopfhörer zum Beispiel geht nämlich auch nicht.
Funktioniert auch nicht? Was macht, da drüben ist so ein kleiner Knopf, da drehst du dann dran?
Ja, dem hab ich schon gezählt. So intelligent bin ich schon, dass ich einen Lautstärke-Regler finde.
Ich komm gleich einfach mal rüber. Mal sehen, wie intelligent du wirklich bist. André, hallo. Also ich geh jetzt erstmal rüber, damit mein Kollege Harald dich überhaupt hört. Und du redest mit Frank währenddessen.
Du hast einen PC zu Hause. Du hast einen PC zu Hause.
Ja, eigentlich ein bisschen älter schon, aber immer ein PC. Hat einen 2700er AMD-Prozessor.
Dann ist er eigentlich so alt.
Naja, aber mittlerweile doch schon wieder. Ja, dazu habe ich drei, vier, fünf Festplatten in einem Rate-Gerät zusammengeschaltet und das Ding läuft eigentlich permanent.
Hast du dir schon mal überlegt, wie viel das denn so im Jahr ausmacht?
Naja, ich hab da so ein kleines Strommessgerät, was mit dem momentanen Verbrauch anzeigt, und das Ding zeigt mir permanent so gute 100 Watt an. Also 100 Watt Leistungsaufnahme.
Das ist noch relativ wenig eigentlich für das System.
Dann machst du nicht so viel damit, ne?
Naja, das Ding hängt in einem P2P-Netzwerk und schert da knappe 1 TB Daten.
Privatkopien sozusagen.
Und ist eigentlich auch immer gut belegt und immer gut ausgelastet. Also das Einzige, warum er nicht so viel Strom zieht, ist der TFT-Monitor.
Ja, na der Monitor kann aber in den 100 Watt noch nicht mehr drin sein. Das stimmt was nicht. Dann würde ich fast mal vermuten, aber das wollte ich an der Stelle eigentlich noch nicht erwähnen, dass das Messgerät unter Umständen nicht das misst, was du tatsächlich auch bezahlst. Das ist mit Leistungsmessgeräten nämlich ein bisschen komplizierter. Da gibt es eigentlich nur wenige teure Leistungsmessgeräte, die wirklich die Leistung anzeigen, die auch der Energiekonzern abrechnet. Da gibt es unterschiedliche Leistungen. Da gibt es die Wirkleistungen, Scheinleistungen, Blindleistungen. Das hat etwas mit Phasenverschiebungen zwischen Strom und Spannung zu tun. Aber das wollen wir jetzt nicht zu Anfang der Sendung erörtern.
Aber da gibt es... Wir haben dieses Mal bei der Wikipedia, das ist von der Chaosradio.ccc.de Homepage auch verlinkt, da haben wir so eine Mitmachseite. Und da ist eine ziemlich große Linksammlung. Da haben auch schon andere Leute außer uns was eingetragen. Aber da ist ein ziemlich interessanter Link genau zu dieser Problematik, wo bei der CT, in der Computerzeitschrift, das genau mal erklärt ist, warum du da möglicherweise nicht das richtige Mist oder nicht so viel Mist wie der Computer wirklich verbraucht.
Also aufgefallen, dass es irgendwo doch schon richtig sein muss, war, als ich meinen Monitor dran, also einen richtigen CRT, also einen Kartonstrahlmonitor, da habe ich gemerkt, das Ding ging auf 210 Watt hoch. Und das war mir irgendwo schon verständlich. Also der Kartonstrahlmonitor knappe 110 Watt nimmt, ist für mich schon plausibel.
Ja, aber der TFT, guck mal drauf aufs Netzteil oder so, also irgendwie 60 oder so wird der auch brauchen. Also das ist auch so ein bisschen ein Zugschluss, da wollten wir sicherlich auch noch im Laufe der Sendung mal draufkommen, dass die TFT-Monitore so viel sparsamer werden als die Röhrenmonitore. Da ist zwar ein Unterschied, ja, aber so groß, wie wir alle immer denken, ist der nicht. Und wenn man so ein TFT mal ein bisschen anfasst, oben und hinten, dann merkt man auch, das wird richtig schön warm.
Ja und vor allem die Energiebilanz gerade bei diesen Geräten ist nun gerade nicht so schön.
Das ist natürlich wieder ein interessanter Aspekt. Spontan kann ich darauf nicht antworten in dem konkreten Fall. Aber bei CAT-Monitoren hast du halt auch alle möglichen Schwermetalle drin und das Glas muss mal gegossen werden und so. Also da ist auch nochmal Energieaufwand. Was bei den TFT-Monitoren, aber ich wollte da jetzt gar nicht ins Detail gehen an dem Punkt, den Unterschied oder einen großen Faktor ausmacht, ist, dass die Ausfallquote bei der Produktion von den LCD-Finances relativ groß ist. Das heißt, unter Umständen für jeden verkauften TFT kann es sein, dass du einen oder so nochmal mitproduzierst oder vielleicht nur einen halben, der wieder in die Tonne wandert, noch in der Fabrik, weil einfach da zu viele kaputte Pixel im Despekt.
50-50?
Ich weiß nicht, wie hoch die Rate war oder ist mittlerweile, wie hoch die die gesteigert haben. Also vor 3-4 Jahren hat man noch von 3 zu 1 Ausschuss zu Nutzen gesprochen, aber das hat sich sicher gedreht mittlerweile.
Ich denke mal, die Fertigungsmechanismen und Fabriken sind einigermaßen präzise geworden, sodass man den Ausschluss ein bisschen reduzieren konnte, denke ich mal. Weil ansonsten würden die Preise nicht so in den Keller gehen.
Ist davon auszugehen. Gut, aber das ist jetzt gar nicht der Thema gewesen.
Aber wir sind natürlich jetzt in der Zeitreiche geworden.
Das ist schon ein Thema, aber...
Nehmen wir mal, wenn er 100 sagt, nehmen wir doch mal 130 oder so. Wie viel das im Jahr jetzt ist. Hast du dir selber schon mal Gedanken gemacht?
Ich war nur ziemlich erschrocken. Das Ding lief das letzte halbe Jahr gut drei Monate permanent durch. Und meine Stromrechnung für mich alleine beliefe sich auf 350 Euro für dieses halbe Jahr. Und das war für eine Person doch schon ziemlich doll, fand ich. Und ich denke, mein hoher Anteil ist auch von diesem Ding da drinnen. Natürlich fehlt mir da die mathematischen Kenntnisse, um nachzurechnen.
Das ist ganz einfach. Man kann ja einfach sehen, was eine Kilowattstunde kostet. Das steht auf deiner Stromrechnung drauf oder auf der Webseite von deinem Stromanbieter. Und dann kannst du einfach mal...
Ja, gut, kommen wir vielleicht noch drauf. Ich habe es dir mal kurz ausgerechnet nebenbei mit meinem stromverbrauchenden Notebook. Das sind 1160 Kilowattstunden im Jahr, die du mit dem Rechner verbrauchst, wenn ich jetzt keinen Rechenfehler drin hatte.
Ich glaube so, was können wir so ansetzen? 20 Cent, ist das realistisch? Kommen wir mal über Strom, 20 Cent.
Ja, 20 Cent ist realistisch. Ich sage mal ein bisschen so unter, auch für 17 Cent oder so teilweise. Aber je nachdem, was du für einen Anbieter hast. Wenn ich das jetzt mal annehme, das wären 20 Cent, dann wären es 232 Euro im Jahr bei dir.
Nur für den Rechner? Das ist eine Menge.
Vor allen Dingen ist es deswegen ziemlich viel, wenn man sich immer Gedanken macht, wie viel Geld gebe ich zum Beispiel für meine Flatrate aus? Und dann eben nicht einrechnet, was das im Monat bedeutet, allein an Strom, was da noch oben drauf kommt, nur, dass sie die Kiste anrücken. Da warst du wahrscheinlich auch geschockt, oder?
Auf jeden Fall. Nach einem halben Jahr Rechner nutzen, erstmal 350 Euro Strom abdrücken. Und Wäsche waschen habe ich bei Mutti zu Hause gemacht. Ja Mensch, das war ja immer äußerst aufschlussreich.
Ja, jetzt ist nur die Frage, wie kommt man drum herum? Vielleicht können wir da heute Abend ja auch nochmal ein bisschen drüber reden, wie das mit dem Stromsparen jetzt wirklich funktioniert, weil so hohe Rechnungen, wenn man es benutzen will, kommt man ja irgendwie nicht drum herum, den Rechner zumindest anzuhaben. Allein mit Voodoo und mit guten Gedanken wird er nicht warm.
Das könnte eine Möglichkeit sein, also die ganzen Stromsparmechanismen und was ich beim Kauf von einem PC auch schon vorab beachten kann, da werden wir mit Sicherheit später noch zu kommen, ja.
Dank dir, Andre.
Haben wir jetzt endlich mal Musik eigentlich?
Ich werde es jetzt nochmal probieren. Ja, ich habe dem Gerät auch gut zugeredet. Es ist halt so, und das ist echt ein großes Problem bei diesen Sendungen, Geräte haben eine eigene Seele. Und wenn du mit Stromverbrauch ankommst, dann bin ich auch bockig, ne? Da sagt so ein CD-Spieler natürlich auch, pass mal auf, Keule, kann dir mal zeigen, was Stromsparen ist. Ich gehe einfach nicht an. Jetzt spielt er Tischtennis anstatt Musik. Na, das ist ja dann doch noch Musik geworden. Ihr hört Fritz, den Blue Moon Chaosradio heute Abend. Wir haben gerade erst angefangen. Thema heute Abend Strom. Und zwar nicht, dass ihr euren Stromanbieter wechseln, sondern welcher der tollste ist, sondern generell wie viel Strom ihr verbraucht mit Unterhaltungs- und IT-Elektronik. Also alles, was ihr so aufladen müsst und am Netz habt. Gerade eben hatten wir ja schon das Beispiel von jemand, der seinen Rechner einfach ein bisschen länger dran hatte, weil er da so einen Filesharing-Client am Laufen hat, 24-7 und wie die Stromrechnung dann aussah. Das waren ganz schön viele Euro, die der da gezogen hat. Der Florian ist am Telefon. Hi Florian. Wie ist es bei dir auch? So groß?
Na ich habe auch einen AMD 2700 Plus.
Mit 4 Festplatten.
Läuft auch tagtäglich mit DSL 5000.
Hast du da noch einen DSL-Router dazu? Den muss man ja auch noch rechnen.
Noch nicht.
Meiner ist gerade abgeraucht.
Hast du denn mal überschlagen, was du da so jährlich reinbutterst an Strom?
Die BWAK hat mir jetzt eine Erhöhung geschickt und da bezahle ich jetzt so an die 2500 kWh im Jahr.
Das sind in Euro?
In Euro ungefähr 500, müssten es sein.
Wollte ich mir nicht rechnen.
Das ist aber jetzt schon für alles oder nur für den Rechner?
Nee, das ist meistens mal ein Rechner, was ich halt hier benutze.
Bei vier Festplatten brauchst du keine Heizung mehr, ne?
Nee, da ist ein kühler Meer drin und der ist ein verheizendes Wohnzimmer.
Das kann ich mir gut vorstellen.
Hast du einmal darüber nachgedacht, ob du das irgendwie senken willst, senken kannst möglicherweise?
Na, wenn, dann muss ich Festplatten ausbauen.
Aber ich brauche halt mal einen ganzen Festplattenspeicher, weil ich einen FDP-Server drauf habe, wo mehrere Leute doch zugreifen müssen, können, dürfen, wie auch immer, und muss erreichbar sein.
Klar, das ist natürlich, also geht mir auch so, seit ich irgendwie DSL-Flatrate hab zuhause, läuft halt irgendwie mindestens eine Kiste immer.
Und wie der vor mir gesagt hat, dass er dann irgendwie ein Desktop hinstellen würde, ja bloß ein Desktop ist eigentlich für einen Daubetrieb eigentlich nicht wirklich ausgelegt, oder?
Das ist egal. Das hat damit jetzt eigentlich nichts zu tun. Also die Unterscheidung, Desktop oder Server, PC oder was auch immer, das ist eigentlich eine eher marktspezifische Unterscheidung, weniger eine technische.
Sind so richtige Serverstrukturen eigentlich darauf ausgelegt, dann auch Strom zu sparen oder spielt das überhaupt keine Rolle?
Nee, ganz im Gegenteil. Man überdimensioniert alles, damit auch ja nie was ausfällt.
Im Gegenteil, du brauchst ein zweites Netzteil ein, genau.
Redundanz, ja. Du stellst dir zwei Server hin, wenn einer ausfällt, vielleicht sogar noch drei, um die Verfügbarkeit zu erhöhen. Nicht nur die Server, sondern auch dann die Netzwerkeinfrastruktur. Alles wird doppelt und dreifach ausgelegt. Ganz im Gegenteil, also an Stromspann denkt dann niemand. Da ist die Klimaanlage.
Und Heizung für den Dieselaggregat, damit er im Winter schneller anspringt.
Jaja, das kommt dann dazu. Gerade so Rechenzentren und so, da kann man dann auch noch mal eine ganze Sendung drüber machen, wo diese überall Strom vergeunen.
Na, das wäre spannend, wenn da jemand Profi ist und vielleicht in einem arbeitet, dem muss er keinen expliziten Namen nennen, könnt ihr einfach mal anrufen, damit wir vom Profi-Segment auch so eine kleine Äußerung dazu haben, wie viel da so abgeht.
Wie viel Strom braucht eigentlich eine Webseite? Wie viel Strom verbraucht eigentlich die Fritz-Webseite? Das wäre mal irgendwie...
Die sind bestimmt runtergerechnet, ja klar, wir müssen sie auf den Preis runterschlagen.
Pro Klick.
Ja, das wird natürlich dann schon ein bisschen schwierig, aber auch die 100 oder 130 Watt, die wir beim vorherigen Telefonat hatten, die sind also wirklich noch sehr tief gegriffen. Also wenn da jetzt jemand irgendwie einen Server laufen hat und da sind noch ein paar Mehrfestplatten dran und dann habe ich noch, was weiß ich, einen externen USB und eine externe Platte und vielleicht noch, was weiß ich, was für Geräte außenrum stehen und einen Switch und einen Router und so weiter, dann kommt das wirklich schnell auf 200, 300, 400 Watt oder vielleicht sogar noch mehr. Also wenn ich dran denke, was bei mir daheim alles so läuft, also da laufen so drei, vier Rechner immer die ganze Zeit durch und also irgendwie vier Switches und da kommt einfach viel zusammen.
Aber auch für den ganz normalen Einzelrechner, also ich sehe es ja als Spieler ganz oft, in Foren zum Beispiel, da steht dann, ja das Spiel ist scheiße, ich spiele mit meinem Rechner 10 Minuten und dann freeze oder aus. Und das sind ja ganz oft Sachen, die mit dem Netzteil zum Beispiel zusammenhängen, weil die haben dann eine fette Grafikkarte drin und die fette Grafikkarte, funktioniert das Spiel nicht. Die Grafikkarte zieht so viel Strom von dem Netzteil, dass der Rechner, wenn du Pech hast, irgendwann aufgibt. Also solche Sachen zum Beispiel.
Ja, eine Frage. Kann man denn mehr Geld sparen, wenn man ein anderes Netzteil einbaut?
Ja, es gibt effizientere Netzteile, das ist richtig. Da wird auch ein bisschen was getan. Es ist so, dass ein Netzteil zwar auch lastabhängig, das heißt, wenn der Rechner mehr Strom zieht, mehr Strom verbraucht, dass das Netzteil dann auch mehr aus dem Stromnetz entnimmt. Aber du hast halt immer so eine gewisse Grundbelastung auch, was einfach durch den technischen Aufbau von diesen Schaltnetzteilen, von diesen Computernetzteilen bedingt ist und da ist noch ein bisschen was drin auf jeden Fall. Gut, es ist ja das, was das Netzteil dann wirklich dann theoretisch liefern kann. Das heißt ja nicht, dass es das immer verbraucht, sondern es ist schon lastabhängig ganz deutlich. Na ja, hast du gerade gehört, so eine Grafikkarte, die überrundet mittlerweile deutlich den Prozessor. Ich weiß nicht, wie das ist. Hast du da Zahlen? Ich weiß nicht.
Grafikkarten stecke ich nicht drin. Also bei Prozessoren kommt es halt auch immer sehr darauf an. Können wir vielleicht auch nochmal erwähnen an der Stelle, dass der Stromverbrauch der Computer immer deutlich ansteigt. Also mit jeder neuen Computergeneration werden die Rechner schneller, aber was halt die meisten Leute vergessen, ist, dass sie dann auch deutlich mehr Strom brauchen.
Ich habe hier eine Tabelle vor mir, die sagt, für den Dual-Opteron, Dual-Xeon, was schon so richtig das dickste und fertigste ist, was man sich heutzutage zu Hause hinstellt, da liegen wir so bei 360 Watt.
Nur für den Prozessor oder was?
Nur für den Prozessor. Also es sind zwei, allerdings muss man fairerweise sagen. Pentium 4, was haben wir hier, Prescott, was auch immer, bis zu 310 Watt, einer allerdings nur. Atlon 64 liegt so bei 160 Watt.
Das sind aber komplette Systeme jetzt, das ist nicht nur der Prozessor alleine.
Also hier steht Prozessortyp, da weiß ich nicht, ob sie darauf...
Nein, es geht um komplette Systeme. Aber okay. Also einzelne Prozessoren, da sind wir im Moment bei den ganz schnellen über 3 Gigahertz Pentium 4, sind wir so bei 120 Watt oder so, was der Prozessor alleine brauchen kann im Höchstlastfall.
Aber im Grunde können die doch nicht ewig so weitermachen. Auch wenn die Entwicklung so ist, wie viel verbraucht ein Herd, wie viel verbraucht eine Waschmaschine im Vergleich, dann ist dann der Computer irgendwann das im Haus, was den meisten Strom verbraucht.
So weit sind wir noch nicht, aber das ist auch tatsächlich ein ernsthaftes Problem, dieser Stromverbrauch, weil die Strukturen in den Prozessoren, die werden ja immer feiner, immer kleiner. Man ist jetzt bei 90 Nanometern mittlerweile irgendwie angelangt. Und das heißt, die Hitze entsteht auch auf immer kleinerem Raum. Und ich muss die Hitze ja verteilen, um die irgendwie abzuführen, um die Luft abzugeben beispielsweise. Und das ist tatsächlich ein wesentlicher Bremsfaktor bei der Prozessorentwicklung mittlerweile, dass man einfach die Wärme nicht mehr wegbringt.
Aber so etwas wie Energieeffizienzklassen, was ich zum Beispiel bei der Waschmaschine auch habe, da protzen die ja mit irgendwelchen As und A-Doppelplus und so, so was gibt es für Rechner noch nicht. Also wenn man daraufhin malen Aldi oder einen Lidl-Rechner untersuchen würde, wird es wahrscheinlich auch spannend werden.
Also es gibt da so eine Maßangabe in Anführungszeichen oder so eine Rechnung, das sind die MIPS pro Wattleistung. Also die MIPS sind die Mega-Instructions per second, also die die Anzahl oder die eigentlich eine Angabe der Schnelligkeit der Rechner, wie viele Rechenoperationen pro Sekunde die machen können. Und das kann man schon auf verschiedene Prozessortypen umrechnen oder anlegen, so eine Zahl. Und da kommen da schon recht unterschiedliche Werte aus.
Ja, also früher hat man sehr viel auch noch, also sagen wir mal bis 2000 oder so hat man diese Angabe MIPS per Watt tatsächlich noch häufiger mal gelesen. In den letzten Jahren taucht die immer weniger auf. Weil, also schon alleine die Klassifikation eines Prozessors, wie schnell ist der jetzt wirklich, das kann man nicht so an einem Wert festmachen. Also dieser MIPS-Wert, der kommt dann wieder darauf an, wie der berechnet ist und was dafür Berechnungen gemacht wurden und so weiter. Und dementsprechend trickst das dann natürlich auch jeder Hersteller so hin, dass er wieder besonders gut dasteht mit den MIPS per Watt. Und der Prozessor selber ist heute ja auch nicht nur mehr ein Prozessor, sondern da sind auch andere Elemente wie ein Cache mit drauf, der auch wieder Strom braucht und das verschwimmt dann alles so und deswegen wird diese Angabe auch nicht mehr genutzt. Aber es ist tatsächlich ein Problem, dass es für keine der Komponenten im Rechner, abgesehen vom Prozessor, irgendwelche Stromverbrauchse in der Energieeffizienzklasse oder sonst irgendwas gibt, ja überhaupt keine Angaben zu eigentlich nichts, keiner der PC-Komponenten.
Aber vieles steigt jetzt auch durch die Wasserkühlung und dann kommt jetzt bleuchte der ID-Kabel raus.
Na, die Wasserkühlung selber braucht eigentlich wenig Strom. Da hast du nur eine kleine Pumpe, die halt das Wasser antreibt, aber die braucht vielleicht so 5 Watt, 10 Watt maximal. Das ist kein großer Bestandteil. Die Wasserkühlung führt nur dazu, dass du den Rechner noch schneller bauen kannst, weil du die Wärme schneller wegbringst von dieser Entstehungsquelle, dem Prozessor, der Grafikkarte oder was auch immer. Das heißt, indirekt kannst du durch die Wasserkühlung wieder schnellere und noch mehr stromverbrauchende Rechner bauen. Ja, das ist leider wahr.
Dann viel Spaß mit deiner Stromrechnung weiterhin, Florian. Der Arne aus Liebhe, hallo Arne. Du hast?
Ja, ich wollte erzählen, also wir in Liebhe, wir spielen so öfter mal ein Netzwerk, also wir sind dann auch zu zehnt oder mehr und uns ist halt auf jeden Fall in das eben, wenn man viele Rechner so dran hat, dass es halt sehr viel Strom verbraucht und wir wissen jetzt zur Zeit nicht mehr so richtig, wo wir das machen sollen, weil keiner von unseren Eltern würde mehr so richtig bezahlen.
Wie habt ihr denn das festgestellt, dass das so viel Strom verbraucht? Wie seid ihr da so aufgekommen?
Na, also erstmal durch die Stromrechnung, also ich weiß nicht genau, wie viel das gekostet hat und uns sind ab und zu mal die Sicherungen rausgeknallt.
Ah ja, ja.
Und ist aber schon ein deutliches Lied dafür, dass die Rechner wirklich viel verbrauchen. Also wenn ihr da, wie viel wart ihr denn da?
Zehn, zwölf Mann, also so sind wir.
An einer Sicherung?
Ja.
Ah.
Das ist uns auch passiert, wir waren damals, glaube ich, 24 und wir wussten dann irgendwann ziemlich genau, welche Steckdosen im Raum an verschiedenen Sicherungen angebracht sind, um das also verteilen zu können. Und manche von uns mussten dann über eine ganz lange Skala im Flur quasi angenuckelt sein.
Das Interessante ist, bei Grafikkarten verbrauchen die ja auch nur Dahnstrom, wenn sie belastet werden. Also ich kenne das von einer Grafikkarte bei mir, die hatte ein bisschen Probleme mit der Kühlung. Und wenn ich dann so ein richtig fettes 3D-Spiel aus dem Zweise mal anhatte, dann hat die irgendwann die Geräte gemacht und war einfach zu heiß, überhitzt. Und wenn ihr dann so richtig loslegt und dann richtig Action ist und dann knallt die sich unten raus, natürlich auch ganz schön blöd.
Vielleicht sollte man der Frage auch nochmal, weil wir immer von Hitze und von Stromverbrauch usw. sprechen, noch mal kurz den Zusammenhang vielleicht erläutern. Also der Strom, der verbraucht wird, die Energie bleibt ja immer erhalten. Das heißt, die Energie, die irgendwie über die Stromleitung hineinkommt in den Rechner, die muss auch irgendwo wieder raus und ich meine, das bisschen Energie, das in Form von Licht vom Monitor abgestrahlt wird oder das irgendwie in Form von Schallwellen aus dem Lautsprecher kommt, das ist natürlich ein ganz geringer Bestandteil und die restlichen 99,999% oder so der Energie, die hineingepumpt werden, die wird also nur in Form von Wärme wieder abgegeben durch die unterschiedlichen Teile in den Rechner.
Wie bei einer Glühlampe auch.
Eigentlich die absolute Verschwendung, das dann mit einer Wasserkühlung wieder abzufangen, die selber Energie braucht um zu funktionieren.
Ja, ich hab daheim in meinem Arbeitszimmer, also ich arbeite daheim in meinem Arbeitszimmer, ich hab den ganzen Winter die Heizung nie angehabt.
Ja gut, du hast natürlich auch ein bisschen mehr da stehen als Otto Normalverbraucher wahrscheinlich.
Ja gut, aber ja, es ist einfach extrem. Also der Verbrauch ist nicht unerheblich.
Ja, das kann ich mir gut vorstellen. Okay Arne, ja dann such doch mal die Rechnung raus. Obwohl du willst deine Eltern jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht dran erinnern an den Vorfall, ne?
Ich würde nur sagen, so ein Kumpel von mir, der ist dann auch so sinnlos, der hat dann auch irgendwelche Neon-Licht an dem Rechner dran. Und jetzt zieht der dann bloß noch mal richtig, oder?
Schöne blauen Kartonsachen und so, ne?
Ja genau, und der würde das Partie nicht ausmachen, ich weiß doch nicht warum.
Naja, so viel ist das nicht.
Also im Vergleich zur Grafikkarte ist das wahrscheinlich vernachlässigbar.
Ja und dann würden wir mal fragen, also wenn ich jetzt einen Kühler, also zieht ein Kühler mehr Strom oder wird dadurch ihr Strom gespart?
Also der Kühler braucht an sich schon ein bisschen Strom, das kannst du nicht vermeiden, aber du brauchst den Kühler, weil dir sonst deine Komponenten zu heiß werden und durchbrennen.
Also ich glaube die Frage war, wenn ich es richtig verstanden hatte, ob ich jetzt wenn ich eine bessere Kühlung habe, weniger Strom verbrauche oder?
Nein, das ist nicht so.
Genau.
Die Kühlung hilft dir nur die Energie, die du sowieso verbrätst, irgendwie effizienter abzugeben an die Luft, aber mehr bringt das nicht.
Ja und ich wollte noch an die Telekom sagen, dass du lieber endlich mal DSL-Leitung legen sollst.
Ja genau, DSL, wir wollen endlich Internet überall in Deutschland, das geht ja so gar nicht.
Genau, vor allem in Opalgebieten.
Richtig. Die hören immer zu hier bei uns, die wissen, dass wir einmal appellieren pro Sendung mindestens. Übrigens mit dem Modding und dass das keinen Strom verbraucht. Was ich neulich gesehen habe, waren 5, 25 Zoll Schacht Zigarettenanzünder, also insofern, es gibt da einiges, was auch gerne mal Strom zieht und Strom ziehen kann. Wir haben es 22.30 Uhr, ihr könnt weiter anrufen, 0317097110. Thema Stromverbrauch von Unterhaltungselektronik, das muss natürlich nicht nur der Rechner sein, da sind wir aber gerade mal eben. Da könnt ihr mitmachen hier beim Chaosradio und wir machen jetzt kurz Nachrichten.
Wenn Fritz in Frankfurt oder dann 101, 5.
22.32 Uhr genau zu sein. Mit dem Wetter heute Nacht so ein paar Wolken, aber eigentlich kein Regen, es hieß Werte zwischen plus zwei und minus zwei Grad. Morgen anfangs so ein bisschen Nebel, aber später wird es dann schön mit viel Sonne und Wolken. Die Höchsttemperaturen liegen zwischen neun und zwölf Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Matthias Kerkoff.
Das Umweltministerium in Potsdam befürchtet, dass die Grenzwerte der Europäischen Union für Feinstaub in diesem Jahr auch in mehreren Brandenburger Städten überschritten werden könnten. An erster Stelle gelte dies für Kotbus, Frankfurt und Bernau über Fahrverbote, werde aber nicht nachgedacht, hieß es. Zum Jahrestag des Kriegsendes vor 60 Jahren planen mehrere Berliner Kirchenkreise eine Lichterkette. Sie soll am Abend des 7. Mai einmal quer durch die Hauptstadt gehen. Für die 33 Kilometer lange Strecke werden mindestens 25.000 Teilnehmer benötigt. Das Motto lautet nie wieder Krieg, nie wieder Rechtsradikalismus, nie wieder Rassismus. Der Parteirat der schleswig-holsteinischen SPD hat Koalitionsverhandlungen mit der CDU zugestimmt. Die Gespräche sollen bereits am Montag beginnen. Weder SPD und Grüne noch CDU und FDP haben genug Landtagssitzungen, um eine Regierung zu bilden. In Tschechien ist die sozial-liberale Koalition unter Ministerpräsident Gross zerbrochen. Die Christdemokraten beschlossen, sich aus dem seit 2002 amtierenden Bündnis zurückzuziehen.
Das mit dem Marianplatz ist lange her und nach meinen Informationen ist das auch verjährt.
Obwohl... 0331 70 97 110. Das ist eine Telefonnummer. Das ist Chaosradio hier, 20 vor 11. Ihr hört Fritz und das Thema heute Abend vom Chaos Computer Club Stromverbrauch. Und dieser Stromverbrauch-Kiste bei Unterhaltungselektronik und bei Elektronik schlechthin macht einen natürlich... Also man kriegt sofort Paranoia. Ich überlege jetzt hier, wenn ich auf die Telefonleiste schaue, wo ja ungefähr zehn Leute gleichzeitig anrufen können, wie viel Strom verbraucht ihr damit, dass ihr als kleines Lichtchen da blinkt. Also es soll nicht heißen, dass ihr ein kleines Licht seid, sondern es heißt einfach, dass das natürlich auch Strom verbraucht. Genauso wie die Tat, dass ihr hier anruft, was ja auch wieder Strom verbraucht. Und ihr hört uns ja, was für euch Strom verbraucht. Wir senden, was auch wiederum Strom verbraucht.
Ja, wir streamen auch.
Wir streamen auch, was auch Strom verbraucht. Wo streamen wir überhaupt?
Na, wir haben die Chaosradio.ccc.de Homepage und da sind die Streams verlinkt. Wir streamen in drei unterschiedlichen Bitraten, in zwei unterschiedlichen Formaten.
Verbraucht es weniger Strom, wenn man in einer kleineren Bitrate eigentlich nicht, ne?
Doch, schon, weil, also die kommen drauf an, die Decoding-Leistung, das heißt also, ich meine, wenn die Leute uns zuhören, dann muss ja der Prozessor auch arbeiten, der CPU muss arbeiten, um das zu decodieren, zu entpacken. Und dann macht das zumindest vielleicht bei der Bitrate keinen Unterschied, aber bei der Art der Codierung, des Codierverfahrens macht das schon was aus.
Das verästelt sich ganz schön, das Thema. Man merkt das schon, man kann ganz schön in die Details gehen. Und das solltet ihr bei euch zu Hause vielleicht auch mal tun, wenn ihr jetzt gerade so sehr relaxed da sitzt und denkt, ihr hört einfach nur Radio um euch herum, funktionieren ganz viele kleine elektronische Geräte der Unterhaltungselektronik. Möglicherweise ist euer DVD-Player im Stand-by oder ist der aus? Hat er überhaupt einen Ausknopf? Wie viele Geräte haben keinen Ausknopf mehr? Was mich zum Beispiel auch interessiert ist, die Netzteile, die zum Aufladen dienen, zum Beispiel vom Handy. Wenn ich dieses Netzteil reingesteckt lasse, verbraucht das Strom? Na ja, man wird aufmerksam auf so einiges. Wenn ihr auch gerade aufmerksam werdet, 031 70 97 1 1 0. Und am Telefon ist noch mal der Andre aus dem Auto. Immer schön ranfahren, das spart Sprit.
Okay, ich habe drei Sachen. Erstmal noch mal für Arne, der vor dem Anruf ab und rumgejammert hat, dass er kein DSL kriegt. Einfach bei der Telekom jede Woche einmal anrufen, das hilft.
Manchmal.
Ohne Scheiß, das habe ich bei meinen Eltern auch gemacht. War ein Opal-Gebiet und läuft wunderbar jetzt mit DSL.
Jetzt mal auf dich neulich bei der Telekom angerufen, paarmal, das läuft dann immer so. Ja, hier ist mal Lottky, ist denn der Techniker schon unterwegs, der mir heute meinen DSL-Anschluss für die Fremdfirma legen soll? Ja, ich gucke mal eben nach. Ne, da steht gar nichts drin, also da kommt heute garantiert niemand, ja? Ich gehe runter, hängt der Zettel dran, habe sie leider nicht angetroffen. Ich habe mich jetzt gefragt, was hat mich mehr geärgert, dass der Typ es nicht geschafft hat zu klingeln, obwohl ich da war, oder dass die selber nicht wussten, dass sie jemanden losschicken. So viel zum Thema Anrufen.
Das ist kein Problem von der Telekom, es ist ein Problem von allen großen Firmen. Das zweite ist, ich kann euch sagen, die Verlustleistung, die Wärmeleistung, die eine Grafikkarte der neuen Generation, also so eine ATI Radeon X800 XT zum Beispiel, ist alleine 100 bis 120 Watt.
Ist echt viel.
Von insgesamt wie viel? 200? Von wie viel Watt insgesamt? Also wie viel wird sozusagen genutzt davon?
Da stand nur in der CT nicht, da ging es halt nur um Kühlung und dann gesagt, Wärmeleistung 100 bis 120 Watt.
Ja, das ist alles. Also ich meine, die restlichen 0, 5 bis 1 Watt, die das Ding vielleicht noch tatsächlich effektiv irgendwas tut, was du nicht den Wärme umwandelst, das ist ein Problem.
Das ist ein Problem, das ist ein Problem, das ist ein Problem. Das ist ein Problem, das ist ein Problem, das ist. Und in diesem Keller standen nur Akkus. Für die Stromversorgung, für den Notstromversorgung. Dann stand auf dem Dach ein Dieselaggregat und im Keller, also unter den Akkus, noch ein Dieselaggregat mit jeweils 4.000 Liter Diesel. Dazu natürlich passende Klimaanlagen immer. Dann war das ganze Reichszentrum mit zweimal 16 Terabit angebunden an alle großen deutschen und internationalen ISPs. Und wenn man die drei Stockwerke hochgegangen ist, war in jedem Stockwerk dieselbe Fläche, die unten am Akku stand, oben an Survern, Klimaanlagen etc. Und das Ding hatte Betankung für aus der Luft und Betankung von der Erde, also per LKW. Was so möglich wäre. Und dann das nächste war, was wollte ich erzählen?
Scheiß vergessen, Fahrt verloren. War ja auch ganz schön viel, was da jetzt gerade rausgesprudelt ist. Betankung aus der Luft.
Und das zweite war... Genau, Hamburger Energieversorger, da gibt es einmal die Hamburger Energieversorger Nord und Süd. Und beide waren separat an dieses Haus angeschlossen.
Ja, sagen wir mal, machen die überhaupt Gewinn?
Ja, nicht wenig.
Aber hast du mal die Stromrechnung von denen gesehen?
Okay, gut, wir lassen das mal sickern, ja?
Ja, wunderbar.
Gut, danke André. Ja, ist ja fast wie bei mir zu Hause, so von der Anbindung her. Der Alex ist am Telefon. Hi Alex.
Tagchen.
Wie sieht es bei dir aus beim Stromverbrauch?
Es ist ganz schön schwierig, weil ich finde einfach, dass es ein bisschen problematisch ist mit den Herstellern. Also ich bin ja heutzutage teilweise gezwungen, mir Rechenmaschinen zu Hause hinzustellen, die jenseits von Gut und Böse sind. Also ich musste mir jetzt notgedrungenerweise vor einem halben Jahr einen neuen Rechner kaufen, P4. Und da wird einem dann schon schlecht, wenn ich überlege, was ich für Komponenten im Rechner habe, bezogen dann auf den Stromverbrauch.
Das finde ich nicht mehr so feierlich.
Und wenn ich sage, na gut, mir würde vielleicht ein Pentium 3 ausreichen, wo bekomme ich ein Pentium 3 her? Deshalb finde ich es schon wichtig, dass man auch zusehen sollte, zumindest zu Hause, am privaten Rechner, dass man irgendwie zusieht, irgendwie auf Strom zu sparen.
Wie viel benutzt du denn den Rechner? Wie lange ist der eingeschaltet?
Also arbeitstechnisch auch, also ich sage mal, sechs, sieben Stunden am Tag schon. Das lässt sich ja auch leider nicht vermeiden, aber das ist natürlich schon irgendwo eine gewisse Problematik da. Ich würde es dann eben monitorauszuschalten, wenn ich nicht da bin, oder eben Platten auszuschalten. Ich fände es zum Beispiel auch sinnvoll, von Intel oder AMD eben solche Stromsparfunktionalitäten, wie sie auch in Notebookprozessoren implementiert sind, auch auf den Desktop zu bringen. Dass man eben sagt, Speedstab, PowerNow, und dann eben die Takt-Sequenz runterregeln kann. Was soll ich mit im Office-Betrieb? Was soll ich mit 2, 8 Gigahertz?
Braucht kein Mensch.
Also das haben ja die CPU-Hersteller mittlerweile auch ein bisschen erkannt, dass das eine ganz gute Idee ist.
Hat sich leider noch nicht auf dem Markt jetzt durchgesetzt oder große Verwaltung gefunden, aber da gibt es die ersten Ansätze. Das werden wir sicherlich sehen in Zukunft, dieses sogenannte Thermal Management, also das thermische Management von Rechnersystemen. Weil du meintest, du wurdest gezwungen, diesen Rechner zu kaufen und so weiter. Was man natürlich bei der ganzen Sache nicht übersehen darf, ist nicht jedermanns Sache, das verstehe ich auch, aber Gebrauchtrechner ist halt der Punkt. Wenn ich jetzt wirklich einfach absolut keine Verwendung habe für einen Rechner, der diese Leistung bringt, dann kann ich einfach einen alten Gebrauchten nehmen. Was die Energiewilanz auch noch dadurch verbessert, dass man keinen neuen Rechner irgendwo erzeugen muss, wo wir später noch drauf kommen, wenn man auch ganz enorme Energiemengen verschlingt, die Produktion von so einem Rechner überhaupt.
Ja, gut, das ist aber ein Argument. Also Gebrauchtrechner, denke ich, wäre an der Stelle vielleicht wirklich die bessere Wahl. Im Endeffekt ist für mich die wahrscheinlich bessere Wahl gewesen, weil ich kann die 2, 8 Gigahertz nicht annähernd ausnutzen, weil das mache ich Internet, Office, ein bisschen Programmieren, Linux, was auch immer, und da brauche ich die 2, 8 Gigahertz einfach nicht.
Was man natürlich machen kann tatsächlich, das ist aber natürlich nicht dynamisch, also wenn du nie diese 2, 8 Gigahertz brauchst, dann kannst du die CPU auch runtertakten. Also du kannst sie auch einfach mit einer geringeren Taktrate betreiben und dadurch zum Beispiel Strom sparen. Ja, stimmt. Wann hat man den Fall, wo man tatsächlich nie die Geschwindigkeit braucht?
Gibt es da keine Tools für, also irgendwas, was ich mir runterladen kann, was mein Betriebssystem sozusagen dazu befähigt, das zu tun?
Das geht meistens nicht unbedingt nur in Software, da musst du schon in der Hardware irgendwelche Jumper umsetzen oder so.
Also die Idee ist, den Prozessor einfach hardware-mäßig langsamer laufen zu lassen. Das heißt, das ist ja von außen.
Ja, das war schon klar, aber so Speedstab-Technologie oder so, die ermöglicht das eben halt Software.
Ja, das ist aber alles erst bei den Mobilprozessoren. Richtig gut.
Wir kommen nicht drum rum irgendwie. Was ich mich zum Beispiel gefragt habe, welche Festplatte verbraucht weniger Strom? Eine mit einer langsameren Umdrehung oder einer mit einer schnelleren? Weil ich ja die Daten schneller bekomme und...
Weiß ich nicht, ob man das so pauschal sagen kann. Festplattenhersteller geben aber in den Datenblättern sehr wohl die Leistungsaufnahme an der Platte. Also das ist schon was, was man nachschauen kann.
Aber das ist natürlich eine Frage, also wenn das Ding jetzt nicht irgendwie 24 Stunden jeden Tag läuft, ob dir das wirklich dann sozusagen das Wert ist, also wie viel es einfach prozentual ausmacht. Also wir haben bei uns auf der Seite auch mal so eine Tabelle gemacht, die ist jetzt im Moment noch leer. Die können wir jetzt auch nicht hundertprozentig ausfüllen, aber wir wollten mal eigentlich mal versuchen, rauszubekommen, wie ist eigentlich dieser prozentuale Anteil, was verbraucht, welche Komponente im PC verbraucht eigentlich wie viel Strom oder wie groß ist der Anteil daran?
Ja, ich denke, da ist die CPU schon ein massiver Faktor, weshalb eigentlich auch Speedstab und solche Technologien dringend notwendig sind. Aber ich meine, es ist schade, nicht die Festplatte abzuschalten, weil wenn ich sie nicht brauche, wenn ich nicht schreibe auf die Platte oder nichts von der Platte lese, dann würde ich auch vom Betriebssystem abschalten lassen.
Ja, das hat aber wieder den anderen negativen Nebeneffekt, dass so eine Festplatte, also dass das Lager, das diese Platte aufhängt, das mechanische Lager, das altert eigentlich nur beim Ein- und Ausschalten so richtig kräftig. Und eine Festplatte hat quasi zwei Zahlen, die ihr Haltbarkeitsdatum angeben. Das eine ist, wie oft du sie ein- und ausschalten kannst, wie oft sie ein Powercycle überlebt, das andere, wie viele Stunden sie quasi die Scheibe am Drehen halten kann. Und das ist ähnlich wie bei Leuchtstoffröhren zum Beispiel. Ich weiß nicht, ob das bekannt ist. Wenn man die zu oft ein- und ausschaltet, dann geht die Lebensdauer auch runter.
Die Energiebilanz auch. Also, verschlechtert sich.
Okay, dann könnte ich also gegenrechnen, ist es teurer, ja wohl Festplatten sind sehr billig geworden, ist es teurer, den Computer das ganze Jahr laufen zu lassen oder mir regelmäßig eine neue Festplatte zu kaufen? Ey, man fängt natürlich an nachzudenken.
Naja, das mit den Festplatten ist ja eher das Problem, dass es sich dann immer ärgert, wenn sie gerade kaputt gehen.
Gut, die I-Platten sind ja eigentlich dafür ausgelegt, dass man eben hoch und runter fahren kann, was bei Stasi-Platten ja nicht so ist, die jetzt in dauerhaften Betriebsgruppen.
Du hast ja einfach ein mechanisches Problem, das Hochfahren, das verbraucht ja auch selbst wieder Strom.
Ja, aber ja, klar.
Also, es ist irgendwie, irgendwann kommt's von hinten und vornehin wird man nicht klar. Das ist irgendwie sehr verzweckt, die ganze Geschichte.
Alex, danke dir für den Anruf.
Können wir ja noch ein bisschen über die Komponenten reden, wenn wir schon dabei sind. Es hängt natürlich immer sehr von dem einzelnen PC, aber wenn ich jetzt mal so ein typisches High-End-Gerät, irgendwie im, sag mal, noch Consumer-Bereich, nicht professionell, aber halt ein High-End-PC, wie ich ihn heute kaufen kann, mir vorstelle, dann ist mit Sicherheit der Prozessor das, was potenziell die meiste Leistung braucht, potenziell, sag ich, weil das ja auch immer ein Unterschied ist, macht der Prozessor nichts, dann hat er so eine Grundaufnahme, oder wird er jetzt beansprucht, dann steigt die Leistung da ganz dramatisch an, die er aufnimmt. Also Prozessor würde ich mit Sicherheit mal bei über 50% ansiedeln, dass dessen, was so Leistung verbraucht, bei durchschnittlicher Belastung, mit der Ausnahme jetzt noch dieser extremen High-End-Grafikkarten, aber die zähle ich jetzt mal nicht in den typischen PC rein, das ist ja doch eher so ein spezielles Segment. Und dann ist es auch so, dass diese Grafikkarten, wenn jetzt eben nicht beansprucht werden, brauchen die ja auch nicht diese volle Leistung, die sie tatsächlich irgendwie mal aufnehmen. Das Netzteil selber, hatten wir vorhin auch schon mal angesprochen, das hat auch nur einen bestimmten Wirkungsgrad. Wirkungsgrad heißt eben sozusagen, wieviel wird verloren bei der Umwandlung der Energie. Also das Netzteil wandelt ja um von Netzspannung auf eine niedrigere Spannung und das geht nicht irgendwie mit 100% Effizienz, sondern eben mit einem schlechten Wirkungsgrad verliert man halt vielleicht schon mal so ein Drittel bis die Hälfte irgendwie, je nachdem, was das für ein Netzteil ist, geht da schon irgendwie drauf an der Stelle.
Gibt es da eigentlich Empfehlungen? Ich will ja auch mal was mitnehmen für den nächsten Rechner, den ich baue.
Das ist eben das Problem. Es gibt wenige Hersteller, die da wirklich Zahlen veröffentlichen dazu und wenn dann, dann musst du wirklich irgendwie gucken, dass du die ausführlichen Datenblätter bekommst und so und wer macht sich schon die Mühe.
Dann gibt es wieder, dann gibt es wieder Streuungen, dann haben die gerade neue Serie gemacht, also gerade Sachen, die jetzt relativ günstig angeboten werden, da kannst du einfach nie davon ausgehen, dass wenn du einen Testbericht hast und drei, vier Monate später so einen Netzteil kaufst, dass dann auch wirklich das noch die gleichen Werte hat. Weil dann sind irgendwelche Bauteile ausgetauscht worden, es gab Materialstreuungen und alles, die haben die Konstruktion geändert, irgendwo Kosten eingespart und dann kann ich es halt schon genau hingucken.
Also sagen wir es mal so, der Redakteur von Heise, der gerade zuhört, also in drei Monaten hätte ich es gerne, vielleicht ist es dann...
Es gibt, die haben die Testen sowas, die testen dann aber vor allem auch auf die Störempfindlichkeit und Stabilität, aber auch Geräuschentwicklung ist ja bei Netzteilen auch ein wichtiges Problem, da ist dann ein Lüfter drinnen, da werden wir sicherlich auch noch zu kommen zu den ganzen Geräuschgeschichten, Lüfter, Wasserkühlung und sowas, was wir da noch machen können, aber das ist natürlich auch ein Problem, also was trägt eigentlich zu dem Lärm, bei dem so ein Rechner produziert, das ist ja auch nicht ganz unbeträchtlich.
Wobei man natürlich schon sagen kann, wenn ein Netzteil einen sehr hohen Wirkungsgrad hat, dann entsteht gar nicht viel Wärme, dann brauche ich auch keinen Lüfter, der so schnell dreht, um die ganze Wärme abzutransportieren. Also es gibt da schon auch wieder einen Zusammenhang an der Ecke. Ansonsten natürlich auch andere Komponenten, also auf dem Mainboard, das sind ja der Chipsatz beispielsweise, der auf dem Mainboard verbaut ist, der braucht also auch Strom, das hängt tatsächlich auch immer ab, was das jetzt für ein Mainboard ist. Dinge, die relativ gering nur eingehen, üblicherweise sind so Sachen wie Netzwerkkarten zum Beispiel, die sind also im unteren Bereich noch mit einzuordnen, oder Soundkarten beispielsweise. WLAN-Karten? WLAN-Karten brauchen schon auch Strom, ist aber jetzt in so einem Desktop- oder Workstation-PC auch eher im geringen Bereich einzustufen. Für ein Notebook ist es schon wieder viel, was so eine WLAN-Karte verbraucht.
Und in so einem WLAN-Router, wenn wir mal die Gegenstation gleich noch mit ins Spiel nehmen? Weil viele Leute haben ja jetzt so ein Ding da stehen, und es ist halt an und gut ist.
Ja klar, die verbrauchen Strom auf jeden Fall. Wobei da zum Glück keine dicken Desktop-Protestoren sind. Da ist ja irgendwie nicht ein Pentium 4 drinne und keine dicke Grafikkarte. Und da sind üblicherweise CPUs drinne, die schon eher ein bisschen Strom ausüben.
Und die Sendeleistung zieht nicht so viel.
Das ist nicht so der ausschlaggebende Punkt. Die Sendeleistung ist ja äußerst gering bei diesen Wireless-Geräten. Du willst ja damit nicht dein Hähnchen warm machen, sondern du willst tatsächlich nur irgendwelche Signale übertragen. Nichtsdestotrotz kann man schon so 15-20 Watt rechnen für so ein WLAN-Druhter, sage ich jetzt mal. Das ist jetzt, wenn ich sage, ein PC braucht vielleicht 200 mal so irgendwie im Mittelfeld gewirken.
Das ist schon einiges dann für so ein kleines Ding.
Man muss da wirklich betrachten, die haben alle wieder ein Steckernetzteil extra. Das hat dann auch schon wieder einen schlechten Wirkungsgrad. Dieses Steckernetzteil wird auch wieder heiß. Einen schlechten Wirkungsgrad merke ich immer, wenn irgendwas heiß wird. Wenn ich jetzt da fünf Steckernetzteile von meinem USB habe und von meinem Drucker und vom DSL-Druhter und von was sonst noch was in der Steckdosenleiste stecken habe und ich fasse da mal hin, dann wird das richtig heiß. Da habe ich also auch schon wieder den ersten Verlust, bevor ich überhaupt noch mal daran denke, was bei dem eigentlichen Prozessor oder bei den Teilen verraten wird. Auch was wir noch nicht so explizit angesprochen hatten, wir hatten vorhin mal kurz Stand-by angesprochen, ist ja bei Unterhaltungselektronikgeräten, CD-Player, DVD usw. da kennt man das Fernsehen, spricht man immer wieder vom Stand-by-Verbrauch. Bei PCs denkt komischerweise selten jemand dran, dass diese PCs, die seit 1998 oder so verbaut werden, die haben alle das sogenannte ATX, da ist auch kein echter Netzschalter mehr dran. Also die kann ich nicht wirklich ausschalten. Die schalte ich zwar aus, oder ich denke, ich schalte sie aus, aber in Wirklichkeit läuft da auch immer noch so ein Stand-by mit, um irgendwelche Funktionen bereitzustellen, wie zum Beispiel Wake Online, also dass ich übers Netzwerk meinen Rechner einschalten kann, die eh kein Mensch im Privatbereich benutzt. Dafür brauchen wir wieder alles Strom.
Also diese Unsitte, keinen ordentlichen Netzschalter zu haben. Ein richtiger Netzschalter ist ein schalter, ein mechanischer Schalter, der wirklich das Gerät vollständig vom Strom trennt, also so, als wenn ich einen Stecker rausziehe. Genau, wenn sie nett sind, das ist eine ganz, ganz große Unsitte. Es gibt eine Aktion, die haben wir auch verlinkt von unserer Seite, also von der Wiki, von der Mitmachseite, die heißt, keine Ahnung, stoppt den Stromklau, und da gibt es dann ein paar Beispielrechnungen, wie viele eigentlich jedes Jahr bei drauf geht, alleine durch diesen Stand-by-Modus. Und es gibt auch Zahlen aus Japan, wie viele Leute bei ihrem Video-Recorder, bei ihrem VHS-Video-Recorder, da blinkt einfach diese Uhr, da steht ein 0, 0. Das heißt, die benutzen auch diese Timer-Funktion gar nicht. Das heißt also, der Grund, warum diese Geräte eigentlich diesen Stand-by-Modus haben, wird bei 40% der Video-Recorder gar nicht genutzt. Da kann man das Ding auch einfach bequem vom Netz trennen. Webseite dazu ist www.no-e.de, aber ist auch alles verlinkt. Chaosradio.ccc.de und dann auf die Mitmach-Seite, da findet ihr alle Links zur Sendung.
Und da findet ihr auch die Streams und könnt dann irgendwie neben dem Radio noch auf die andere Seite ein bisschen mit Verzögerung hören.
Nein, nein, wenn ihr den Rechner sowieso anhabt, könnt ihr einfach den Stream hören, statt euren Tuner noch zusätzlich einzuschalten.
Oh Gott, die Aspekte heute Abend, fantastisch. Am Telefon ist der Sebastian, hallo Sebastian.
Es gibt ja diese Steckerleisten mit dem Schalter drinnen. Wie sinnvoll sind die? Kann man das machen? Einfach wirklich alles was an dieser Steckernetzeile ist?
Mittlerweile gibt es so 10-
12-fach die ganzen Zeiten, wo vielleicht der ganze Rechner, der Bildschirm, der Scanner und sonst, wo die ganzen Router noch dran hängt, einfach über den Schalter abschalten.
Also es gibt zwei Varianten davon. Es gibt einmal die mit einem richtigen Schalter. Und dann gibt es sogenannte Master-Slave-Steckdosen. Das ist also eine Steckdosenleiste, wo eine Hauptsteckdose drin ist, wo dann zum Beispiel der Computer reinkommt. Und die anderen Steckdosen sind nur eingeschaltet, wenn dieses eine Hauptgerät auch Stromverbrauch eingeschaltet ist. Das heißt, ihr müsst dann nicht immer nach dem Schalter greifen, sondern wenn also der Computer ausgeschaltet wird. Ich hoffe mal, dass sie auch so clever sind, dass sie eben in so einem Standby-Geschichte dann trotzdem auch die Geräte ausschalten. Da müssen wir gucken. Aber das ist die Idee von diesen Master-Slave-Steckdosen, dass die also dann die gesamten Geräte, die da mit dranhängen, dann automatisch auch ausschalten, wenn das Hauptgerät ausgeschaltet wird. Die sind auch gar nicht teuer, kosten 20 Euro.
Weil ich habe mal gesagt, dass es spezielle Drucker gibt, die sollte man nicht vom Netz trennen, weil die so eine Autoreinigungsfunktion hat. Wenn man die trennt, kann dadurch schneller die Patrone verschmutzen.
Das ist richtig, ja. Bei Tintenstahldruckern gibt es sowas in der Tat, dass immer wenn der Tintenstahldrucker eingeschaltet wird, dass dann die Patrone gereinigt wird. Und wenn ich jetzt zehnmal ein- und ausschalte, dann wird die Patrone zehnmal gereinigt. Und beim Reinigen wird nichts anderes gemacht, als dass man Tinte durchpresst durch die Düsen in großer Menge, um sozusagen alles wegzukriegen, was da vielleicht verklebt sein könnte. Und damit geht Tinte verloren. Den Drucker schaltest du halt nur dann ein, wenn du den Drucker brauchst. Das ist eigentlich die ideale Lösung dafür. Und dann wird auch nur die Düse gereinigt, bevor du irgendwas ausdrückst. Und wenn du weißt, du drückst vielleicht in einer halben Stunde noch mal was aus, dann lässt du ihn an, bevor du ihn wieder ausschaltest und wieder einschaltest.
Das heißt, man kann nicht davon ausgehen, wenn man im Moment den Drucker immer vom Netz abnimmt, dass der Drucker beschädigt wird oder so?
Beschädigt wird er nicht, aber der Verbrauch an Tinte kann bei einigen Modellen, die diese Funktion haben, tatsächlich steigen.
Und wir wissen ja mittlerweile auch, dass Tint teurer ist als Edelperfüm. Das heißt, das ist schon ein Kostenfaktor.
Ja, es gibt ja noch zwei andere Sachen. Ein Supertipp, was ich festgestellt habe, ist, wenn man sich mal auf diesen ganzen optischen Laufwerten raufschaut, und man blickt drauf, was die an Strom fressen, da steht oft immer ein schönes Ampere-Drein drauf, gerade bei den 12 und bei der 5-Vort-Leitung. Das ist manchmal ganz praktisch, wenn man die direkt trennt, wenn man sie nicht braucht. Man entzündet ja nicht jeden Tag von irgendwelchen optischen Medien auf einen Rechner.
Na ja, das ist eingebaut, das Laufwerk zu trennen, denke ich, ist schon ein bisschen schwierig. Das sind ja auch immer nur Maximalbelastungen. Also das sagt ja auch nichts über den Dauerstromverbrauch aus. Sondern bei einem DVD-Brenner ist das zum Beispiel der maximale Strom, der beim Schreiben am schnellsten äußeren, also wenn das Ding am stärksten belastet wird, dann ist das der maximale Stromverbrauch und sagt jetzt nichts aus, wenn das Ding einfach nur da dran ist.
Über diese neue Datenleitung, diese Serial Art, das soll irgendwie auch Play-fähig sein, kam da eigentlich schon manche Hersteller auf die Idee, vielleicht das auf dem Mainboard mit integrieren, dass es dann wirklich erst die Festplatte anspricht, dass man dann anfängt zu starten, vielleicht in der Zeit, wo man es nicht wirklich braucht?
Na ja, da brauchst du jetzt eigentlich keine spezielle Funktion am Mainboard. Also dass man Festplatten sozusagen in den Spin-Down machen kann, also diesen Motor abschalten, der die Festplatte selber dreht, das haben Platten also schon seit, würde man sagen, 10 Jahren oder so. Benutzt wird es eigentlich hauptsächlich in den Notebooks, wo man eben auch einstellen kann, na ja, wenn fünf Minuten keine Aktivität, dann dreht die Platte wieder runter und dann beim nächsten Zugriff dauert es halt wieder ein paar Sekunden länger, bis die volle Umdrehungsgeschwindigkeit wieder hergestellt ist. Diese Funktion, die ist also in allen Festplatten, auch die in Desktops oder Servern oder sonst irgendwo verbaut sind, existiert, man kann das auch konfigurieren. Sowohl in der Linux als auch in der Windows kann man das einstellen, dass diese Festplatte eben dann wieder runterfährt.
Und wie weit spart man damit wirklich Strom, oder wird da einfach nur mal wieder so genannt eine supergeniale Stromsparkfunktion?
Na doch, zum Beispiel, ich habe in einem Rechner mehrere Festplatten drin, nicht weil ich den Platz brauche, sondern weil ich unterschiedliche Betriebssysteme installiert habe, die nicht unbedingt auf einer Festplatte auch koexistieren wollen, zum Beispiel. Und da mache ich das dann schon so, dass die andere Platte, die nicht benutzt wird, die wird dann einfach runtergefahren. Und das nutzt dann schon, also die Platte war dann auch gar nicht mehr heiß. Das bringt schon was. Nur wenn ich jetzt alle fünf Minuten natürlich irgendwie Platte hochfahre, Platte runterfahre, dann bringt es nichts.
Gut, und noch eine Sache, was sehr interessant ist, wenn man versucht, seinen Rechner einmal möglichst leise zu bekommen, es gibt ja dieses Silence-Spatel mittlerweile, ich glaube, da kommt man dann auch sehr schnell in diesen Bereich rein, wo man dann automatisch anfängt, ein bisschen Strom zu sparen bei seinem Rechner. Also gerade wenn man anfängt, eine Grafikkarte sich aufzusuchen, die einigermaßen leise ist, da kann man sich gerade nicht unbedingt nachher eine Grafikkarte reinschrauben, die so sonst was für einen fetter Lüfter drauf hat.
Also ich denke, dass die Lautstärke, die ein PC produziert, ist auf jeden Fall schon mal ein recht guter Indikator, auch für den Stromverbrauch oder wie viel drüber nachgedacht wird.
Ich meine, der Stromverbrauch von der Karte, nur weil ich die Wärme besser abführe, ist doch der Stromverbrauch nicht geringer.
Naja, da muss halt ein Lüfter drauf sein und je mehr Wärme der abführt, also ein Ventilator, je mehr Wärme der abführt, desto größer oder desto schneller muss er sein, lauter wird er.
Das ist immer nur für die Maximalbelastung natürlich. Der Lüfter muss immer so ausgelegt sein, dass er im Höchstlastfall und bei höchster anzunehmender Raumtemperatur immer noch genügend Luftzirkulation und Abwärme herbeiführt. Das ist eben schon ein Indikator für den Energieverbrauch dahingehend, dass eine Grafikkarte, die von vornherein nur 10 Watt brauchen kann, die hat gar keinen Lüfter.
Das ist schon klar, aber wenn ich eine High-End-Grafikkarte so passiv kühle, dass sie ohne diesen harten Lüfter funktioniert, dann geht es ja eigentlich nur um den Stromverbrauch dieses Lüfters, der dann so schnell rotieren muss, oder nicht?
Nein, das bringt nichts. Das ist dann nur wieder eine Verteilungsgeschichte. Wie ich auch schon mit der Wasserkühlung erwähnt habe, die spart keinen Strom, sondern die führt nur eben dazu, dass ich die Hitze besser ableiten kann. Aber deswegen ist die entstandene Hitze die gleiche. Das ändert also nichts an dem Punkt. Aber wenn ich jetzt explizit einen Leisenrechner mir kaufen möchte, dann kann ich ja von vornherein eine Grafikkarte kaufen, die eben nicht so viel Hitze produziert, insbesondere dann, wenn ich die Funktionen gar nicht brauche, für diese ganzen 3D-Spiele.
Okay, Sebastian.
Ja, danke.
Danke auch für den Anruf. Das Chaosradio auf Fretz 5 nach 11. Thema heute Abend, werdet ihr vielleicht mitbekommen haben, Stromverbrauch von Unterhaltungs-Elektronik und IT-Geräten. Und da gibt es eine Menge Ecken, an denen das passiert. Am Telefon ist die Sophie. Hallo, Sophie.
Hallo.
Wo wir gerade bei Grafikkarten waren, kommt deine Frage wahrscheinlich auch direkt nachgeprescht.
Ja, genau, ich hatte nämlich die Frage, ich habe eigentlich ein relativ starkes Netzteil, und zwar, ich glaube, 380 Watt. Und habe aber eine Grafikkarte, weil ich endlich mal ordentlich zocken wollte, bei der mir früher auch schon mal abgeschmiert ist, eine 9600er SE radieren. Und die Sache ist die, der friert immer noch ein, aber ich habe das mit einem kleinen Trick, also wenn ich zum Beispiel so Need for Speed Underground 2 oder so zocke, der friert ein, der stürzt ab, sonst was. Da habe ich erstmal probiert, so Bildschirm zu wechseln, jetzt habe ich meinen schönen tollen TFT-Bildschirm gegen den Röhrenmonitor ge- äh, tauscht und dachte, jetzt funktioniert es endlich, hat immer noch nicht funktioniert. Und mit einem Trick habe ich es nur rausgekriegt, und zwar, wenn ich bei der Taskmanager irgendwie dieses CS-Ghost oder so beende, dann habe ich zwar keinen Ton im Spiel, aber ich kann ordentlich zirken. Aber warum ist das so, dass der einfach immer abschmiert? Das kann doch nicht nur am Netzteil liegen, oder?
Nee, ich denke auch, also insbesondere wenn du sagst, du kannst deinem Taskmanager irgendwas abstellen, dann ist das denke ich ein guter Hinweis, dass hier ein Softwarefehler vorliegt und dass das mit der Hardware eigentlich gar nichts zu tun hat. Also egal, was du da für ein Netzteil reinsteckst oder so, das wird, denke ich, an dem Problem nichts ändern. Das hat nichts mit dem Energieverbrauch zu tun, denke ich.
Audio ist auch oft ein Problem bei solchen Spielen, offensichtlich. Also Audio führt auch gerne mal irgendwelche Probleme hervor, die gar nichts mit der Grafik zu tun haben, obwohl die Grafik dann auch darunter leidet. Aber puh, schwierig. Hast du vielleicht eine Onboard-Grafikkarte und die konkurriert mit der Grafikkarte, die da reingesteckt ist, das kann sein? Dann würde ich, der klassische Satz des IT-Verkäufers, haben sie denn ganz frische Treiber von allem. Und dann sagst du, weiß ich jetzt nicht, ja, dann machen sie das erstmal. Mit dem Satz zieht man sich immer aus der Affäre. Das würde ich aber tatsächlich auch erstmal probieren. Grafikkartentreiber, Soundkartentreiber, die Bordtreiber, mittlerweile muss man da ja auch eine ganze Menge aufspielen.
Und dann?
Und den Spoiler am Festplattenkabel nicht vergessen.
Der muss gerade sitzen. Das würde ich probieren. Ansonsten ist es halt wieder über Telefon, was wir jetzt gerade machen, einfach zu schwierig, dass du die diagnostizieren, dann solltest du dir einen besorgen, der immer rumkommt.
Und was mich noch wirklich sehr interessieren würde, war der Stromverbrauch beim 21C3.
Oh, das ist eine gute Frage, aber vielleicht können wir das sogar rausbekommen. Das ist mal eine interessante Sache.
Das war ja irgendwie allein im Hackcenter, ich weiß nicht wie viel, mindestens 300 Laptops habe ich gesehen.
Ach, das ist noch so der gering geschätzt, ja.
Geschätzt, ja und es war zwar klasse, aber ich habe so das Gerücht gehört, dass das Stromverbrauch von der Kleinstadt in einem Jahr ist. Oder war?
Na so extrem denke ich wird es nicht sein. Wir haben jetzt keine Zahlen vorliegen, wir können das denke ich in der…
Ich schreibe es uns, wir kriegen das raus. Also wir können es auf jeden Fall sagen von den Camps, da wissen wir es, weil wir da in der Regel den Strom selbst erzeugen mit Generatoren. Scheinstaub erzeugen? Genau. Aber vielleicht kriegen wir das auch über das BCC, über die Stromrechnung, wenn wir da mal nicht anfragen. Das ist ja immer interessant. Wie viel ist das beim Camp?
Auswendig schwer.
Auswendig weiß ich nicht, aber es war schon viel. Also es waren so ein paar Megawatt. Das ist in Holland, ja genau. Nee, wir wollen auch mal, aber es ist eine ganze Menge von Berlin organisiert und so.
Also das Camp in Holland, wo es in Holland stattfindet, ist also co-organisiert von den holländischen Hackergruppen und vom CCC.
Vor der Berliner. Und ich.
Naja, es ist halt alle vier Jahre in Holland und alle vier Jahre in Deutschland und immer um zwei Jahre verschoben. Wie weit sollen wir in den Winter spielen mit Olympia?
Klar, wir müssen jetzt einen Vergleich mit Olympia machen. Was anderes hätte dem Vergleich auch gar nicht standgehalten.
Ja, sorry, müssen wir passen. Mit viel Glück haben wir vielleicht in zwei Jahren wieder eins in Deutschland.
In Holland werde ich nicht dabei sein, aber beim 22-43 gibt es wieder.
Sophie, neue Treiber und probier beim Spiel auch mal aus, der Soundkarte mehr Power zu geben. Das heißt, mehr Kanäle für die Soundkarte freizuschalten und so, also dass du wirklich...
Und mehr Bass.
Ja, und den Spoiler. Probier das nochmal aus, das könnte manchmal auch helfen. Ah, Mann ey, mit euch kann man echt nicht ernst arbeiten. Das ist so unglaublich. Chaosradio hier übrigens, 10 nach 11 auf Fritz. Thema ist Stromverbrauch. Und im Studio sind wir zu dritt. Der Frank. Und der Max, das bin ich. Das ist quasi die Stimme, die immer so spricht, wie sie spricht. So, jetzt hier nicht auf den falschen Knopf drücken. Sophie, jetzt ist der Robert am Telefon. Hallo Robert.
Hallo.
Auch ein spannendes Ding, was du mitbringst.
Nein, aber es kann sein, dass du übers Jahr gerechnet, möglicherweise oder ganz sicher aber sogar mehr verbrauchen, wenn du ein Netzteil hast, das sich nicht vollständig vom Strom trennen lässt. Was z.B. bei mir der Fall ist, ich habe Firewire-Platten extern und ich springe wirklich im Dreieck, weil die Dinger einfach Strom verbrauchen. Ich müsste irgendwie unter den Tischkrabben einen Stecker rausziehen. Die verbrauchen einfach Strom, wenn sie da liegen. Und wenn du jetzt aber ein Festplattengehäuse hast, wo du richtig einen mechanischen Netzschalter hast, dann hast du es natürlich nicht der Fall.
Was ist mit denen, die über USB oder über Firewire ihren Strom beziehen, die Kleinen?
Na, die verbrauchen genauso viel Strom, als ob es intern ist. Also da ist ja der einzige Unterschied, dass das Kabel irgendwie 30 cm oder 1 m oder 2 m aus dem Gehäuse rausgeht. Das tut dem Energieverbrauch eigentlich keine Änderung an.
Und der Wirkungsgrad?
Der Verlust auf der Leitung ist zu vernachlässigend.
Die Frage war, ob die langen Kabel zur externen Festplatte möglicherweise einen Stromverlust erzeugen.
Das ist eine super Nachfrage. Einfach immer nach dem Wirkungsgrad fragen. Das ist ein Welte-Wort, was ich hier mitnehme. Ein Harald-Wort. Viel Spaß mit der externen Festplatte weiterhin.
Vielleicht nochmal, weil du auch wieder von dem unteren Tischkrabbeln und Steckerzehen gesprochen hast, da können wir wirklich den Hörern und auch dir in dem Fall ans Herz legen, diese Steckerleisten mit Schalter.
Ich gehe gleich morgen in den Baumarkt und kaufe mir so eine blöde Master-Slave-Steckdose. Das ist nämlich genau das, was ich brauche.
Du weißt es ja nicht. Du weißt ja nicht, ob dieses Standby-Ding, was Wake on LAN oder was das auch immer ist, ob das nicht dafür sorgt, dass das Ding anbleibt. Kann doch sein.
Wie viel Watt sind denn das so? Das war sozusagen der Rechner, wenn ich ihn nicht hinten am Netzteil ausschalte, sondern nur vorne so über diesen Taster ausschalte oder einfach nur überrunter fahren, dann ist er immer an. Der muss ja immer ein bisschen Strom verbrauchen, damit auch dieser leichte Tastendruck, also früher gab es ja richtig so einen Klack, so ein Netzschalter bei den alten Computern. Das gibt es ja nicht mehr, sondern das ist jetzt so ein leichter Tippschalter einfach nur. Und damit das funktioniert, muss das System schon immer ein bisschen mit Strom verbraucht werden. Nicht viel, aber mal ein bisschen.
Ist jetzt eine Schätzung, habe ich keine Zahl vorliegend dazu, aber ich würde mal irgendwas sagen, 5 Watt oder so. Irgendetwas um den Dreh. Weil das Netzteil muss ja, es geht ja eben nicht nur um den einen Schalter, sondern es muss einfach eine gewisse Menge an Strom zur Verfügung stellen. Eben auch für den Fall, dass man diese Wake-On-Lan-Funktionen und so diese Sachen. Also da können einzelne Teile im Computer können sozusagen dem Netzteil sagen, na ich will auch versorgt werden mit Strom, wenn der Rechner ausgeschaltet ist. Und dann hängt es halt davon ab, wie viele solche Komponenten sind in dem Rechner und so weiter und so weiter. Und diese Technologie der sogenannten Schaltnetzteile, wie die genannt werden, also die Netzteile, die wir heute eigentlich überall haben, die funktionieren immer nur dann, wenn eine gewisse Last auch dran ist. Das heißt also, wenn ich so ein Schaltnetz baue, dann muss ich in das Netzteil schon mal eine kleine Last selber wieder einbauen, einen Lastwiderstand, der Strom verbraucht, weil sonst das Netzteil gar nicht funktionieren würde. Also das ist so ein technologisches Problem auch noch. Das heißt eben, wenn dieses Netzteil überhaupt Spannung zur Verfügung stellen muss im Stand-by-Fall, dann muss auch eine kleine Last da sein, damit das Netzteil überhaupt funktioniert. Also das ist noch so ein eigenartiger Zusammenhang.
Also ich habe es gefunden, Internet sei Dank. Bei einem großen Elektronikrahmenversender gibt es also diese Master-Slave-Steckdosen und die lassen sich einstellen. Das ist ein kleiner Drehregler von 5 bis 40 Watt, ab wann die eingeschalten werden.
War zu frech von mir an zu zweifeln, dass du diese Information innerhalb von 15 Sekunden hervorzaubern könntest.
Und sie kann es kosten 20 Euro und ich glaube, das habt ihr mit einer Stromrechnung in einem Jahr locker wieder raus, behaupte ich mal. Bei vielen Stand-by-Geräten.
Und vorschalten muss ich dann noch eine Überspannungsschutz-Steckdose?
Das gibt es auch alles in one.
Cool, habe ich auch wieder was.
Aber der Überspannungsschutz hilft dir beim Stromverborgen nicht?
Nee, nicht wirklich. Aber bei anderen Dingen, wie zum Beispiel Überspannung. Der Klaus aus Diebendorf ist am Telefon. Hallo Klaus.
Ich bin aus Diebendorf in der Schweiz. Und ich habe einen Fernseher, der tut sich ziemlich komisch, wenn ich einen von Stand-by in Aus-Zustand schalte. Er verbraucht nämlich im Aus-Zustand definitiv mehr Strom als im Stand-by-Betrieb.
Wollte ich sagen, er ist kaputt?
Ja, das dachte ich mir auch.
Nur, wo er neu war, war das der Fall. Ich bin Elektriker und habe das damals direkt ausgemessen, wo ich ihn gekauft hatte. Ich war also sehr überrascht, dass er im ausgeschaltenen Zustand, wo er die Zeit und die Programme total verliert, mehr Strom braucht als im Stand-by-Betrieb.
Hast du denn das Gerät aufgemacht und innen durchgemessen, was das ist, was da zieht?
Nein, das habe ich nicht mehr. Das ist im Moment auch ziemlich uninteressant, weil der mittlerweile mit Teller zustaubt, und da im Fernseher eh nichts mehr gescheites läuft.
Also es ist entweder eine Fehlkonstruktion oder ein Defekt. Ich meine, da kann ja auch tatsächlich Defekt schon bei der Anlieferung gewesen sein, dass hier noch irgendwas mit dem Netz verbunden ist, obwohl er eigentlich ausgeschaltet ist.
Das wäre eine Möglichkeit. Ja, und die zweite Sache, die mich interessiert, ich habe hier zwei Rechner stehen, die summen schön vor sich hin. Die summen 24 Stunden am Tag vor sich hin. Da habe ich jetzt allerdings noch nicht gemessen, was die alles verbrauchen. Ich spiele jedoch mit dem Gedanken, mir in absehbarer Zukunft ein Silent-Gerät anzuschaffen, das ich hier als Server einsetzen kann. Und wollte fragen, gibt es da schon brauchbare Geräte, die für diesen Zweck geeignet sind? Oder muss ich mir da selber zusammensuchen?
Gibt es. Also diese cool Silent-Reihe, selbst die großen Versandketten sind mittlerweile drauf gekommen. Einen haben sie immer. Das Problem ist, es ist natürlich so ein Orchideen-Ding. Es ist neu, es ist irgendwie Stylo, es ist vielleicht Wasserkühlung oder ähnliches. Dann machen sie das Gehäude noch extra clicky-bunt, damit du auch siehst von außen, dass es irgendwie ganz besonders gekühlt ist. Und dafür wollen sie dann immer in der Regel noch mehr Geld haben. Es ist ja normal, es ist noch kein Massenmarkt einfach. Aber es gibt es auf jeden Fall. Es gibt es auch für Zocker, weil es ist tatsächlich, wir haben ja vorhin das Problem Lahnparty gehabt, wenn 25 Leute in einem Raum ihren Rechner anhaben, dann ist...
Da können die auch ihre T-Shirts ausziehen, das wird ganz schön warm.
Das ist ja immer das Geile gewesen. Das Problem ist einfach, wir haben ja vorhin davon geredet, dass bei normal Temperatur der Lüfter mitkommt. Aber wenn du im Sommer bei geschlossenen Fenster, weil die Nachbarn halten das nicht aus, wenn du die ganze Zeit schreist, wenn du irgendwie die Basis gewiped hast beim anderen, dann noch diese ganze Hitze von den Rechnern. Also insofern, die Gamer-Seite ist da auch mittlerweile dabei. Musst du mal einfach mal die Versandhäuser durchgehen, das gibt es mittlerweile.
Ja, muss ich mal schauen. Witzigerweise ist ein Gerät, das am lautesten ist, ein externes Bandlaufwerk. Das weiß ich noch nicht, wie ich das leise kriegen soll. Da bin ich jetzt momentan noch am Planen, wie ich das Ding leise kriege. Die Grafikkarte kommt mir nicht an, weil ein Server braucht keine Grafikkarte.
Also eine Sache solltest du dir vorher überlegen. Ich habe nämlich ein paar Freunde, die das gemacht haben. Da ging es zum Teil auch um Audioproduktion. Wir arbeiten beim Radio. Da muss auch alles schön leise sein, wenn du nicht irgendwie eine Kammer hast, wo du was einsprechen kannst, wo alles gedämmt ist. Und da gibt es zwei Richtungen, in die man arbeiten kann. Das eine ist, du hast einen ganz normalen Rechner, baust in die Kiste zum Beispiel Dämmmatten ein. Da geht es ja auch um Vibrationen und so. Diese Dämmmatten nehmen die Vibration weg und diese Dämmmatten halten auch Lautstärke im Inneren des PCs. Aber dann hat sich derjenige entschlossen, nachdem er überall Dämmmatten reingekleht hatte, das Ding komplett zu silenzen, indem er die Lüfter rausbaut. Und Dämmmatten halten gut warm. Deswegen musste er die ganzen Dämmmatten wieder rauspacken. Entweder in die eine oder die andere Richtung musste er gehen. Das sowieso nicht. Das ist eine ganz andere Kiste.
Ja klar, bei mir geht es mit zweierlei, einerlei. Der Stromverbrauch ist nicht unerheblich, den die beiden Kisten hier machen. Und im Winter kann ich wirklich damit heizen. Jetzt haben wir eine Wohnung. Und ja, auch irgendwie zum Filme gucken ist es nicht besonders cool, wenn da sauernd ein Summen im Hintergrund ist.
Diese ganzen Multimedia-Home-Wohnzimmergeschichten könnten vielleicht noch eine kleine Trendwende bewirken, dass da aus Lärmerwägungen ein bisschen auf kleinere Komponenten gesetzt wird. Aber das ist in der Regel ja nur ein rechnerndes System, was zusätzlich immer noch kommt. Das heißt, es ist nochmal wieder ein elektronisches Gerät, es sind nochmal Teile, die da stehen, es ist nochmal ein Standby-Modus, der läuft.
Wie ist das eigentlich mit solchen Entwicklungen, die momentan laufen? Also zum Beispiel eine andere Art von Speichertechnik oder sowas wie mit Licht oder so arbeiten. Sind Wirkungsgrade da anders oder ist das alles im Stromverbrauch niedriger, in Erwandlung?
Naja, also ich möchte jetzt nicht irgendwie anti-amerikanisch oder so erscheinen, aber viele der Dinge werden halt in Amerika erfunden und entwickelt und da interessiert sich ja eigentlich so gut wie niemand für den Stromverbrauch und von daher, ich meine, das ist bei uns hierzulande kaum anders. Also es wird daran gearbeitet, dass Dinge billiger werden, er billiger in der Produktion. Es wird daran gearbeitet, dass Dinge schneller werden, aber um die Energieeffizienz kümmert sich niemand. Das kauft ja auch niemand. Also auf den Markt gesehen kauft niemand nach Energieeffizienz ein.
Zumindest nicht bei Computern.
Eben.
Also es hat ja mittlerweile eingebürgert, es gibt diese Energieeffizienz-Labels und so eine Skala, die so ganz viel, kennt ihr bestimmt, wenn ihr mal irgendwo im Elektro-Laden war, an Kühlschränken ist das dran, an Glühlampen auch. Da ist es eine Waschmaschine, da ist eine Skala von A bis G in der Regel. Und da ist denn markiert, wie effizient dieses Gerät mit der elektrischen Energie umgeht. Das heißt also, wie viel wird davon tatsächlich denn verwendet und sinnvoll genutzt. Und bei Kühlschränken sind sie mittlerweile, glaube ich, überall bei A. Das ist ganz okay. Und es wäre mal interessant, wie sowas für Computer aussieht. Das ist natürlich ein bisschen schwierig, weil was wird denn genutzt und so was. Es ist ein bisschen schwieriger zu berechnen vielleicht. Aber um einfach mal den Leuten so ein Gefühl dafür zu geben, wie viel Strom verbraucht diese blöde Kiste eigentlich? Das ist, glaube ich, eine ganz gute Maßnahme, da wirklich auch ein bisschen besser aufzuklären und vielleicht wirklich auch mit diesen komischen Bundenaufklebern von A bis G zu arbeiten.
Was man an der Stelle vielleicht auch noch erwähnen kann, ist, dass es eine Aktion gibt vom Umweltbundesamt in Kooperation mit OBI. Speziell hier in, ist es doch, glaube ich, bundesweit. Wir machen auch sehr viele OBI-Filialen hier in Berlin mit, wo man sich kostenlos Stromwestgeräte ausleihen kann. Wenn man einfach mal prüfen will, wie viel braucht denn jetzt mein Rechner oder was auch immer für ein Gerät, dann kann man dahin gehen, hinterlegt 20 Euro Pfand und leistet sich so ein Messgerät aus und dann kann man das mal messen und bringt man es wieder zurück.
Läuft das einfach so ein Zwischenstecker? Steckt man die Steckdose?
Energiemonitor heißen die.
Ja, konnten wir dir ein bisschen helfen, Klaus?
Okay, ganz kurze Frage. Du bist aus der Schweiz, habe ich richtig mitbekommen. Du hörst uns wie zu?
Ja, über Livestream natürlich. Also Antenne wäre ein bisschen kritisch hier.
Satellit vielleicht.
Ja. Kommt die über Satellit?
Ja, klar. Über Astra.
Gut, ich weiß nicht, ob das hier ins Kabel eingespeist wird.
Ah, wahrscheinlich eher nicht, aber.
Kabel nicht, nee.
Interessant ist es noch, wie das hier in der Schweiz mit der Internetverbindung gegenüber Deutschland aussieht, also was in Deutschland ein Problem ist mit ADSL oder dem TDSL.
Ja, bei euch gibt es Cablecom, das ist ja eigentlich alles ganz easy.
Cable, das hab ich jetzt auch und da hab ich einen symmetrischen Upstream, also das ist wirklich eine brauchbare Angelegenheit.
Das Land ist ja auch ein bisschen kleiner.
Ja gut, aber auch was DSL anbelangt, verkaufe ich das mittlerweile in jeder Stadt hier in der Schweiz.
Habt ihr nicht auch schon eine richtige Handyflat?
Nein, also gut, da hab ich mich jetzt noch nicht großartig drum bemüht, das interessiert mich, reizt mich. Aber was die Kabelgründen anbelangt, da ist Flatrate eigentlich ziemlich üblich, ohne dass du da keine oder nur je nachdem hohe Volumenbegrenzung hast, insofern, ja, das ist ganz praktisch.
Spaß in der Schweiz. Klaus, dank dir. Es war nur ein Wunschtraum, Entschuldigung, ich hab das mal gehört, mein Gott, selber vom Thema abgelenkt. Sechs Minus. Ja, Stromverbrauch. Setzen. Ja, setzen. Kann ich nicht. Ich habe euch beide Stühle gegeben. Der Ben aus Berliner Köln. Hallo Ben.
Hallo.
Mit Mitbewohnern gekämpft, ja. Wie bitte? Mit Mitbewohnern zu kämpfen.
Genau, mit Mitbewohnern zu kämpfen.
Wer hat schon wieder diese Stromrechnung produziert?
Ja, also wir hatten ziemlich hohe Stromrechnungen bekommen und die waren immens hoch.
Und keiner war's.
Weil die BWAC, die hat halt die Tarife geändert. Das heißt also, dass wenn man weniger Strom verbraucht hat, hat man also höhere Preise gehabt und dann mussten wir halt den Stromtarif wechseln, sodass wir halt bei mehr Strom weniger zahlen müssen. Also das ist ziemlich komisch und ziemlich komplex gemacht. Jedenfalls haben wir uns dann alle, wie schon gesagt, so eine Strommessgeräte geholt. Allerdings, die haben wir uns dann gekauft, nicht geliehen und haben dann halt auch mal getestet, was wir halt so verbrauchen alle und ja, also ich würde jetzt eher sagen, dass wir gleich viel verbrauchen, aber wir haben dann auch gucken können, welche Geräte immens viel verbrauchen. Darunter natürlich auch der PC, wobei ich sagen muss, dass ich einen 350 Watt Netzteil habe und aber wenn der PC läuft, auch wenn ich jetzt irgendwie was, zum Beispiel ein Spiel zocke oder so, dann verbraucht er halt auch mehr, wie gesagt und selbst da verbraucht er nur 220, also ganz kann man nicht sagen, dass ein 350 Watt Netzteil auch 350 Watt verbraucht. Nein, nein.
Das ist die Maximalgrenze.
Genau. Und was halt ein guter Tipp von mir, würde ich jetzt sagen und zwar habe ich mir dann bei, ich würde jetzt keine Werbung machen, ich danke jetzt mal Konrad, da habe ich halt so eine Steckdosen, die per Funk halt ausgeschaltet werden können, geholt und wenn ich jetzt irgendwie weggehe oder so, dann drücke ich mal kurz aufs Knäppchen und dann habe ich einen Stromverbrauch von null im Zimmer. Und das ist auf jeden Fall ein sehr guter Tipp, weil wenn man auch weggeht, also so 50 Watt verbrauchen mindestens die Geräte, die alle auf Standby sind und es ist natürlich jetzt in der ganzen Wohnung, die Stecker zu verteilen, ist natürlich blöd, aber sollte man sich auf jeden Fall zulegen, das lohnt sich schon.
Hast du mal nachgemessen, wie viel die Empfänger von diesen Steckdosen verbrauchen?
Die verbrauchen gar nichts.
Also die schleusen den Strom nur durch.
Also ich weiß jetzt, diese Strom-Messgeräte, weiß ich jetzt nicht, die haben jetzt eigentlich Nee, nee, nicht das Messgerät, sondern die Empfänger von diesen Funk-Steckdosen.
Ja die sollten eigentlich, ja okay, die werden warm. Das ist jetzt schon wieder so eine Sache, die habe ich mich noch nicht gefragt, muss ich ehrlich zugeben.
Mess doch mal, hast du ja die Geräte. Also nicht jetzt, aber so generell, du hast ja ein Strom-Messgerät und ein Empfänger.
Dazu muss ich sagen, da verbraucht es nichts, weil wenn ich jetzt das Netzteil drin habe, also diesen Funk-Netzteil, wenn ich das jetzt drin habe und dann halt im Strom-Messgerät auch noch zusätzlich drin habe, weil es sind ja so eine großen Popper, dann steht auf jeden Fall ein Verbrauch von Null drauf, wenn ich den Stecker gezogen habe von den Geräten. Das ist auf jeden Fall eine Tatsache. Und zu den Kühlschränken nochmal, da kam ja auch die Frage, wie viel die verbrauchen. Und zwar haben wir das nämlich auch getestet, weil wir zwei Kühlschränke haben, eine ältere und jetzt vor kurzem haben wir uns eine neuere noch zugelegt, weil halb zu dritt ein Kühlschrank ist nicht ausreichend. Und da habe ich dann gemerkt, wo wir das dann getestet haben, dass der neuere verbraucht auf jeden Fall wesentlich weniger, aber beide, wenn sie jetzt gerade nicht am Kühlen sind, haben sie einen Verbrauch von Null. Aber das hat mich gewundert, weil ich dachte, so ein großes Gerät muss auch Strom verbrauchen, wenn es auch Stand-by ist sozusagen.
Bei Kühlschränken ist es ja so, da läuft ja nur dieser Kompressor, der läuft ja nur wirklich dann. Ich würde sagen, da ist so ein Temperaturschalter drin und dann, wenn gekühlt werden muss, dann läuft das Ding auch.
Es ist auch tatsächlich ein mechanisches Bimetall. Also dieses Thermostat, das das ein- und ausschaltet, das ist überhaupt keine elektronisch sind, sondern das ist nur so ein Bimetall-Streifen, wie man aus dem Physikunterricht kennt. Und wenn da eben die entsprechende Temperatur erreicht ist, dann biegt der sich durch und überwirkt irgendeinen Kontakt.
Wie ist es mit den anderen Geräten, außer jetzt zum Beispiel Fernseher, weiß nicht, was zum Standby-Modus habt ihr da mal irgendwie?
Was anderes, was mir nämlich auch noch eingefallen ist, was sehr viel Strom braucht, was eigentlich niemand denken würde, und zwar normale Lampen, ganz normale Lampen. Wir haben uns nämlich hier, wir haben die komplette Wohnung mit Energiesparlampen ausgerüstet. Manche sagen, sieht hässlich aus, aber mit einem hübschen Schirm, da kommt das Licht dann halt nicht so grell.
Auf jeden Fall, das lohnt sich schon.
Weil wenn man mal überlegt, ein PC, da ich jetzt mal einen 300 Watt Netzteil und verbrauche doch 300 Watt, dann muss man sich überlegen, das sind 300 Watt Birnen. Und irgendwo in der Wohnung hat man eine 100 Watt Birne. 300 Watt Birnen sind halt ein PC, und daran muss man auch mal denken.
Ja, das ist schon richtig, aber ich denke, das ist eigentlich hinreichend bekannt, dass Glühbirnen eine Effizienz von unter 1 Prozent haben.
Da wird unheimlich viel in Licht umgewandelt, habe ich gehört.
Ja, genau, unter 1 Prozent der Energie wird in Licht umgewandelt. Da ist das alles Wärme. Das sind eigentlich keine Lampen, sondern das sind Heizungen. Bei Lampen ist es aber so, dass man insbesondere die helle Beleuchtung... Computer haben doch einige Leute 24 Stunden am Tag an mittlerweile. Sei es aus Bequemlichkeit oder eben wegen irgendwelchen Falsharing oder sonst irgendwelchen Geschichten, aber beim Licht ist es halt, denke ich, doch selten so, dass man irgendwie die Festbeleuchtung den ganzen Tag anhat. Naja, zum PC.
Ich habe hier so einen Computerprofi hier in der Wohnung und der hat dann einfach mal schnell so ein kleines Tool programmiert, wo man dann halt den PC einstellen kann, wann er ausgehen soll. Wenn man zum Beispiel eine Aufnahme hat und so und die stoppt dann halt nach zwei Stunden, dass er dann halt nach zwei Stunden und zehn Minuten ausgeht und so. Also das ist schon ziemlich praktisch. Sollte man auch mal gucken, gibt es bestimmt irgendwo im Internet. Er hat das halt mal schnell mal so gemacht und ich bin damit ziemlich zufrieden. Ich kann es jetzt leider nicht weiterempfehlen, weil ich nicht weiß, wo man das jetzt kriegen kann.
Ja, da gibt es unterschiedliche. Die ganzen modernen Rechner haben sowieso auch das Umgekehrte eingebaut. Die haben eine Zeitschaltuhr, alle eingebaut, mit denen du den Rechner starten kannst. Also du kannst zum Beispiel sagen, morgen um vier Uhr früh soll der Rechner angehen. Und wenn du das dann noch kombinierst mit dem Tool von deinem Freund, wo du dann sagst, naja, nach zwei Stunden wieder aus, dann hast du ja eigentlich schon die komplette Zeitschaltuhr wie beim Videorekord oder so. Ja, dann vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Ich wollte noch ganz kurz sagen, weil es das erste Mal ist, dass ich bei Blumun anrufe, ich grüße dir ganz herzlich Nico und Jesse.
Das wird die beiden freuen. Das ist auch das erste Mal, dass die gegrüßt worden sind. Ich habe noch nichts, das ist doch nur logisch. Ben, Mensch, tschüss, und Jesse und so. Am Telefon ist der Gabriel, wir hatten vorhin was zu externen Festplatten, vielleicht erinnert er euch. Hallo Gabriel.
Hi, also ich wollte zu den externen Festplatten was richtig stellen, weil die kleinen Dinger, die übers USB bzw. Firewire versorgt werden, die brauchen wesentlich weniger Strom, weil da Notebookplatten drin sind, die sind erstmal so, brauchen sie weniger Strom und die normalen Desktop Festplatten, die könntest du nicht über einen USB bzw. Firewire betreiben, weil die einfach zu viel Strom fressen und USB ist bis 500 mW ausgelegt, gibt da irgendein Standard und das würde einfach das Motherboard rauchen.
Das kannst du halt unbedingt vergleichen, weil es ging um die Frage, was jetzt im Vergleich zum Desktop zu den eingebauten Platten, also dann muss ja natürlich...
Er hat dann irgendwer gefragt, wie das ist mit, oder irgendjemand hat er noch was gesagt zu den kleinen Dingern und da hat er ihr irgendwie gesagt, das macht keinen Unterschied, ob es aus dem PC versorgt wird oder über ein sechsternes Netzteil.
Da denken wir wahrscheinlich zu technisch, weil ich meine, du kannst ja auch eine Notebookfestplatte in deinem PC fest einbauen und dann hast du jetzt genauso Spaß. Dann hättest du technisch gesehen wieder Äpfel mit Äpfeln verglichen, also das Gleiche, aber das ist natürlich recht für den Otto-Normalverbraucher. Für uns als Techniker sieht das aus, als ob er Äpfel mit Birnen vergleicht, aber für ihn ist das das Gleiche.
Und ja, dann fällt mir zu dem, während ich gewartet habe, war der Mensch da, der irgendwie einen leisen Rechner oder irgendwie einen energieeffizienten Rechner als Server haben wollte. Ich glaube, Mini-ITX-Geräte, also die, die insgesamt ein kleineres Motherboard haben, deswegen auch ein kleineres Gehäuse, können die fast verbrauchen nicht ganz so viel Strom wie die normalen großen Dinger.
Das kommt natürlich darauf an, was du damit machen willst, also wenn du jetzt wirklich die restlichen Rechenleistungen brauchst, weil du zum Beispiel irgendwie eine sichere Verbindung machst, brauchst du viele Verschlüsselungsgeschichten, du hast einen Web-Server.
Wenn man zu Hause als Server rumstehen hat, dann ist es ja meistens nur ein bisschen Fileserver und macht dann noch Web, wenn er irgendwie da so in so einem Abfall...
Genau, da sind die bekanntesten Boards, die es so gibt, sind die Via Eden-Reihe. Das sind so kleine, die sind so nahe, so 15, 15 Zentimeter. Genau, Mini-ITX, diese Größe, das ist ein ganz kleines Format, die sind auch speziell für diese Multimedia-PC, also jetzt nicht so Wohnzimmergeschichten irgendwie gedacht, für kleine Geräte, können aber auch für Server genutzt werden. Wenn ich also immer nur mal ein bisschen Rechenleistung brauche und das irgendwie zu einem relativ günstigen Preis und mit wenig Stromverbrauch und wenig Abwärme, dann sind die wahrscheinlich genau das Richtige für dich.
Ja.
Gibt's mittlerweile, glaube ich, auch als Zentrino, wenn man ein bisschen mehr Rechenleistung braucht, aber ist da natürlich auch teurer.
Also ich kann genauso gut einfach irgendwie ein altes Pentium-Board oder so nehmen. Also die sind nicht, nur weil die so klein sind, sind die nicht so viel sparsamer, sondern die sind eigentlich im Wesentlichen...
Ja, aber die sind halt deswegen sparsamer gebaut, damit sie in ein kleines Gehäuse können, oder?
Ja, aber sie sind einfach leistungsärmer gebaut, das sind halt irgendwie 600 Megahertz CPUs mit sparsischen Kühlern drauf. Die sind nicht effizienter per se, genau, das ist das, was ich sagen will. Du kannst also auch dir gebrauchten alten Rechner kaufen oder so, oder dir aus alten Komponenten was zusammenbauen und du wirst es genauso effizient haben, vielleicht nicht im gleichen kleinen Gehäuse, aber...
Und du tust das Podcastshow umwelt.
Und dann habe ich noch eine Frage zu den Strommessgeräten, weil ich habe öfter mal gelesen, dass wenn man da die ganz einfachen, also diese Verbrauchsmessgeräte, wenn man da die ganz einfachen nimmt, hätte man mit PCs manchmal Probleme, weil sie so einen dynamischen Verbrauch haben, dass diese Strommessgeräte das irgendwie nicht vernünftig genau messen.
Richtig, die CT hat mal ein bisschen was dazu geschrieben, ist verlinkt von der Mitmachseite in der Wikipedia. Da gibt es irgendwo eine Fragen, Antworten oder bei den Ideen ist das, da ist ein Link.
Das ist das mit der Wirkleistung, Blindleistung, Scheinleistung. Wird aber bei neuen PCs, so denke ich, auch besser, nachdem neuere Netzteile, diese PFC, diese Powerform Correction oder wie auch immer das heißt, drin haben, wo also hier die Aufnahme auch wieder gleichmäßig erfolgen muss aus dem Netz, aber da schweifen wir jetzt dann ab. Das sind nämlich tatsächlich, na ich muss es jetzt doch an der Stelle noch erwähnen.
Ich muss es sagen.
Ja, ich muss, wo wir tatsächlich die Energieversorger Probleme haben und das sozusagen jetzt über Jahrzehnte hinweg eine Rückwirkung in die Unterhaltungselektronik und Elektrobranche hinein bekommt, dass Geräte anders gebaut werden, damit Energieversorger keine Probleme haben. Das ist ein interessanter Prozess.
Jetzt hat er es doch gesagt und ich habe es auch doch nicht verstanden. Ja, das war mir zu unpräzise. Jetzt mal ausführen können, Mensch.
Der Nachrichtensprecher wartet aber schon. Ja sicher.
Mensch, also ein Mann, der mitdenkt. Gabriel, vielen Dank für den Anruf. Tschüss.
Wenn Fritz in Stausberg, dann 102, 6.
Wir haben es nämlich schon fünf nach halb gleich.
Fritz Info.
Fünf nach halb zwölf, um genau zu sein. Mit dem Wetter sieht es so aus. Ein paar Wolken unterwegs, aber keine Regen. Die Tiechschwetter liegen zwischen plus zwei und minus zwei Grad. Morgen fängt der Tag neblig an. Später wird es aber schön, mit viel Sommer und selten Wolken. Und die Höchsttemperaturen liegen zwischen neun und zwölf Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Matthias. Ja, wir warten noch eine Sekunde. Matthias Perkoff ist im Grunde bereit. Also das Wetter ist halt auch heute so schön gewesen, dass man sich ein bisschen Zeit lassen kann.
Das Umweltministerium in Potsdam befürchtet, dass die Grenzwerte der Europäischen Union für Feinstaub in diesem Jahr auch in mehreren Brandenburger Städten überschritten werden könnten. An erster Stelle gelte dies für Cottbus, Frankfurt und Bernau. Über Fahrverbote werde aber derzeit nicht nachgedacht, hieß es. Zum Jahrestag des Kriegsendes vor 60 Jahren planen mehrere Berliner Kirchenkreise eine Lichterkette. Sie soll am Abend des 7. Mai einmal quer durch die Hauptstadt gehen. Für die 33 km lange Strecke werden mindestens 25.000 Teilnehmer benötigt. Das Motto lautet nie wieder Krieg, nie wieder Rechtsradikalismus, nie wieder Rassismus. Der Parteirat der schleswig-holsteinischen SPD hat Koalitionsverhandlungen mit der CDU zugestimmt. Die Gespräche sollen bereits am Montag beginnen. Weder SPD und Grüne, noch CDU und FDP haben genug Landtagssitze, um eine Regierung zu bilden. In Tschechien ist die sozial-liberale Koalition unter Ministerpräsident Gross zerbrochen. Die Christdemokraten beschlossen, sich aus dem seit 2002 amtierenden Bündnis zurückzuziehen. Hintergrund sind undurchsichtige Immobiliengeschäfte des Sozialdemokraten Gross. Der Verkehr Fritz hat keine Meldungen, wir wünschen gute Fahrt.
Fritz präsentiert den Echo 2005.
Der Echo 2005 ist eine Preisverleihung mit angeschlossener Musikgaler, die am Samstag im Berliner Estrell Convention Center stattfindet und längst ausverkauft ist. Da trifft es sich gut, dass Fritz noch Karten hat.
Die letzten Karten für den Echo. Am Echo-Tag ab 10 Uhr im Fritz-Kartengarten gegenüber vom Estrell.
Hinkommen, mitspielen, gewinnen.
Und ab 18 Uhr sendet Fritz live aus dem Estrell das Fritz Echo Radio. Der Echo in Berlin am Samstag und im Radio.
Nothing seems, there for me, need a different measure. I count me in, I count me out, when they say I'm a star.
Ihr hört das Chaosradio auf, Fritz ein bisschen mehr als Halbzeit, Viertel vor, zwölf gleich, das heißt noch eine gute Stunde Zeit zu reden im Chaosradio-Thema heute Abend Stromverbrauch und zwar insbesondere der von Unterhaltungselektronik, IT-Geräten, alles was man so am Netz hat, was stand-by kann oder auch nicht, was sich auflädt oder auch nicht extern oder intern ist, alles was man so braucht.
Mit dem Studio der Frank, der Harald und der Max.
Und das Thema kriegt jetzt mal wieder einen kleinen Schwenk. Also wir waren ja gerade schon bei Kühlschränken angekommen. Die, das muss man euch zugestehen, mittlerweile auch schon fast zur Unterhaltungselektronik zählen. Aber es gibt auch noch andere Ecken.
Wir wollten eigentlich auch noch ein bisschen über das Thema hinausgehen, und zwar in Richtung die Energie, die aufgewendet werden muss, um die Unterhaltungselektronik und oder die Computer überhaupt herzustellen.
Und auch um sie wieder loszuwerden.
Das ist der andere Punkt, ja.
Aber wie viel kann das sein? Ich meine, die ganzen Dinge werden ja auch immer billiger. Wird das irgendwie so rausgerechnet dann? Weil wenn da so viel Energie reingesteckt werden muss, zum Beispiel bei der Produktion, das kostet ja auch Geld.
Oder nicht?
Ja, aber wo wird das Zeug produziert? China? Taiwan?
Okay, von was für einer Energie reden wir und an welchen Stellen ist sie besonders hoch?
Ja, es gibt da wieder mal sehr viel unterschiedliche Zahlen dazu. Es gibt also Studien dazu und Schätzungen und leider sehr aktuelle Zahlen habe ich nicht gefunden. Im Jahr 1998 gab es mal eine Untersuchung, wo man festgestellt hat, dass zum Beispiel 5300 Kilowattstunden für die Produktion von einem Standard-PC damals gebraucht werden an Energie. Das ist also eine ganz enorme Summe. Dazu kommt dann noch, dass insgesamt 11 Tonnen an Material aufgewendet werden mussten. Das ist das ganze Wasser, das man braucht bei der Produktion und auch Mineralien und so weiter und so weiter und so weiter. Um das ein bisschen anschaulicher darzustellen, das hat mal jemand in der Wissenschaft die Untersuchung gemacht, der das dann verglichen hat mit einem Standard-PC braucht es so viele Rohstoffe wie zwei Drittel eines Autos, wobei in dem Auto noch nicht die Elektronik eingebaut ist.
Wobei dann eine interessante Frage ist, warum ist denn das Auto so viel teurer als der PC? Also es liegt offensichtlich nicht an den Rohstoffen, sondern müssen halt andere Faktoren eine Rolle spielen beim Preis.
Das ist natürlich noch mal eine ganz andere Frage, ja. Aber ich meine, nur um das mal zu veranschaulichen, das sind also tatsächlich ganz enorme Mengen, die hier sowohl an Energie als auch an Rohstoffen mit eingehen, in die Produktion von Rechnern. Das wird auch ständig verbessert, die Produktionsmethoden verbessern sich da. Am wichtigsten muss man hier ganz eindeutig auch wieder die Halbleiterproduktion nennen, also die Produktion von den Chips für Prozessoren oder auch Grafikkarten, wo auch immer. Also alles, was irgendwie an Chips verbaut ist in den Rechnern. Und da ist einmal der Sprit, der unglaublich viel Energie braucht, ist das hochreine Silizium herzustellen, das man da braucht. Man muss da ja ein Monokristallin, das Silizium erzeugen. Das ist das ein Kristall, da gibt es keine Brüche drin. Und der eine Kristall, der wird also hochgezüchtet, bis auf 30 cm, das gängige größte Format für Wafers. Da wird ein Kristall gezüchtet, der also einen Durchmesser von 30 cm hat, und der ein einziger Kristall ist. Da muss man also das ja auch schmelzen. Das ist also ein enormer Energieaufwand, der hier mal hineinfließt. Auch Wasser wird entsprechend verbraucht. Es gibt da interessante Zahlen aus Taiwan. Bekanntermaßen wird in Taiwan eigentlich so gut wie alles an Halbleitern und Computertechnologie produziert. Ich habe jetzt natürlich wieder die Seite gerade nicht offen mit den Zahlen. Das ist wieder meine mangelhafte Vorbereitung.
Hast du es gerade?
Ich habe hier die Zahlen von diesem taiwanesischen Technology Park, wo also steht, dass pro Quadratzentimeter von Wafern, das ist also die Seite dieser Chip, sozusagen die Grundfläche von diesen Chips, wo hinterher die Chips draus ausgeschnitten werden. Da sagt man also, dass da, das war jetzt eine Zahl von 2001, dass ungefähr anderthalb Kilowattstunden Strom pro Quadratzentimeter dafür verwendet werden. Das entspricht also ungefähr einem Chip. Das heißt also erst mal nur allein für den reinen Chip erst mal schon zwei Kilowattstunden.
Ja, und das muss man auch sehen, ist nur der Produktionsaufwand. Das ist noch nicht mit eingerichtet. Die Ausschüsse zum Beispiel, also man hat da ja auch immer Ausschussraten dabei und man sägt dann die auseinander. Man hat Verlust, Verschnitt außen herum und so weiter. Also da geht noch einiges dazu. Dann wird das Ganze ja noch in den Chip erst mal verpackt und so weiter und so weiter. Das ist jetzt rein nur die Produktion des Wafers in dem Fall. Interessanter finde ich eigentlich noch, was die Zahl dieses Wasser angeht. Das sind also hier 9 Liter Wasser pro Quadratzentimeter produzierter Chip-Oberfläche, die verbraucht werden. Ja, ja. Und das ist schon bei einem Recyclinggrad von knapp 50 Prozent des Wassers. Also wo die wirklich schon die Fabriken daraufhin optimiert haben, den Wasserverbrauch zu reduzieren an der Stelle. Das ist also nicht zu verachten.
Interessant sind noch andere Rohstoffe, wie zum Beispiel ein Stoff, der wenig bekannt ist. Den nennt sich Tantal. Und der ist drin in den Kondensatoren. Das sind also kleine Bauteile, elektronische Bauteile, die zur Stabilisierung von Strom, von Stromspitzen im Verbrauch, also beim, an den Chips benutzt werden. Damit werden also Sachen abgepuffert. Und da ist ein Werkstoff drin, eine Tantal, das ist Metall. Und das ist also in einigen Ländern ein absolutes Politikum, weil mittlerweile der Verbrauch so stark ansteigt durch die ganze Unterhaltungselektronik, durch diesen sprunghaften Anstieg, dass da also ganze Länder mittlerweile ähnlich wie beim Öl, Kampf um das Öl, da ein ganzes Politikum drum entstanden ist, wie zum Beispiel im Kongo, wo also da eine sehr heikle politische Situation da drum auch entstanden ist. Da kann man ein bisschen was nachlesen, da haben wir auch ein paar Links zu. Das sind also Sachen, die dann auch mal beachtet werden müssen, was denn so links und rechts von dieser reinen Produktion von diesen Chips entsteht und vom Stromverbrauch.
Die Besorgung der Rohstoffe, weil das Coltan ist das Erz, das man braucht, um Tantal herzustellen. Das ist sehr rar. Gibt es nur an wenigen Orten auf der Welt und unter anderem einige mitten in Bürgerkriegsgebieten in Afrika. Und da finanzieren sich also Warlords dadurch, dass sie sozusagen irgendwelchen ausländischen Firmen die Exklusivrechte an dem Coltan vorkommen, sozusagen fördern. Das ist unter Umständen eine relativ blutige Geschichte. Zu dem Tantal noch, das wird hauptsächlich in kleinen Geräten verbaut. Man kann das nämlich, also zu Kondensatoren kann man unterschiedlich verbauen und Tantal wird vor allem, diese Tantal-Kondensatoren werden vor allem in Handys und PDAs, Organisern und diesen kleinen tragbaren Geräten verwendet. Und ja, dazu, wenn man dann bei Handys auch gleich mal bleibt, da ist halt der Lebenszyklus auch noch so furchtbar kurz. Ich habe hier auch Zahlen zu Handys, wenn ich die jetzt wieder irgendwie, ich habe viel zu viele Zahlen hier auf einer Seite. Na, ich glaube, es gibt eine Studie, die sagt, in Europa waren das 40 Millionen Handys, die im Jahr 2005 in den Müll wandern. 40 Millionen. Und wie lange haben Leute Handys? Die, die einen Vertrag haben, haben alle zwei Jahre ein neues Handy. Und dann wird alle zwei Jahre, also sozusagen das Wasser verbraucht für die Chips und was weiß ich, was für Rohstoffe verwendet und so weiter. Und das landet da letztendlich alles im Müll. Vieles davon wird im Hausmüll irgendwie verheizt in der Müllverbrennungsanlage oder so. Von Recycling kann man da leider nur sehr wenig sprechen.
Na, gerade beim Handy ist es natürlich auch nicht besonders auffällig. Wenn du einen Rechner wegschmeißt, fällt es dir selber ja auch ein bisschen besser auf, als wenn du so einen kleinen Knochen irgendwie in den Müll schmeißt.
Und das, wo also allgemein was zu Platinen und diese ganzen elektronischen Schaltkreise betrifft, da sind also unglaublich viele verschiedene, auch Schwermetalle und unterschiedliche Rohstoffe drin. Es gab auch eine interessante Untersuchung, die sagen, in einem Standard-PC sind mehr als die Hälfte aller Elemente, die im Pherjoden-System der Elemente bekannt sind, enthalten in so einem PC, in den unterschiedlichen Baugruppen, die da so sind. Und naja, ein paar kann man ja schon ausschließen, weil die will man nicht in seinem PC haben, so radioaktive, aber da ist unglaublich viel drin. Also in Platinen zum Beispiel finden wir auch häufig immer noch Arsene, in Lötzern ist überall Blei mit drin. Also ja, da kann man sich darüber auslassen. Und das ist also leider alles sehr wenig bekannt und wird auch sehr wenig klimatisiert.
Auch interessant, in den Leuchtstoffröhren bei TFT-Bildschirmen, bei Flachbildschirmen, die sind auch nicht so ganz gesund von der Herstellung. Möglicherweise hat sich es mittlerweile ein bisschen gebessert, aber das ist auch ein richtiges Entsorgungsproblem, wenn die mal weggeworfen werden. Ich weiß nicht genau, was ist das, dieser Leuchtstoff, ich hab's jetzt nicht im Kopf, aber der ist halt auch nicht so ganz ungefährlich.
Und da sind wir auch schon beim zweiten Ding, nämlich der Entsorgung. Das war jetzt alles nur Herstellung und was an der Energie für die Herstellung draufgeht. Entsorgung ist, wenn sie denn stattfindet, auch noch mal krass oder?
Ja, die Entsorgung findet leider Gottes nicht so statt, wie man sie sich wünschen würde. Also in Europa gibt es jetzt eine Richtlinie über die Rücknahme von Altelektronikgeräten und so weiter, wo das besser werden soll. Im Moment ist es halt de facto so, dass die westliche Welt ihren ganzen Schrott irgendwo in die Schwellenländer oder in die dritte Welt exportiert.
Als großzügige Spenden.
Genau, die werden dann als defekte oder als gebraucht Geräte deklariert und nach Indien oder Pakistan zum Beispiel sind da sehr beliebt verschifft. Das sind unglaublich große Mengen, da habe ich auch wieder Zahlen, vielleicht finde ich sie, die da verschifft werden. Und es gibt also eine Studie, die sagt, alleine in der indischen Hauptstadt in Delhi arbeiten 100.000 Menschen daran, Elektronikschrott zu verarbeiten. Das kann man sich dann tatsächlich bildlich so vorstellen, da gibt es auch genug Quellen dazu, die das bestätigen, dass Kinder in irgendwelchen Hinterhöfen stehen und das Taturkabel verbrennen, damit die Isolation verbrennt, um an das Kupfer ranzukommen, was in den Kabeln enthalten ist. Das ist also die Schattenseite unserer IT-Elektronik.
Das ist übrigens auch nicht viel besser bei der Herstellung der Geräte. Es gab Anfang letztes Jahr, also 2004, gab es mal eine Studie von einer christlichen, kirchlichen Organisation, die die Arbeitsbedingungen in PC-Fabriken, wo die zusammengebaut werden, untersucht haben und die haben festgestellt, dass das alles nicht so toll ist da und dass Sachen wie Kinderarbeit und dass Gewerkschaften grundsätzlich verboten sind und jegliche Formen von politischer Betätigung der Mitarbeiter ist also absolut unerwünscht und da herrschen also ziemlich heftige Bedingungen. Es hat sich mittlerweile ein bisschen gebessert, weil da auch wirklich Namen genannt worden sind der Firmen, aber das ist ein Aspekt, den sollte man auch mal betrachten, unter welchen Arbeitsbedingungen die eigentlich hergestellt werden. Das ist natürlich auch die Folge davon, dass alles mal billiger, immer effizienter hergestellt wird, muss ich mir als Konsument natürlich auch überlegen, wo kommt das her? Ist es wirklich nur die technische Weiterentwicklung oder wird auch an anderen Stellen ordentlich gespart?
Die menschliche Energie, die da verbraucht wird sozusagen.
Ich habe auch Zahlen noch gefunden zu der Entsorgung. Es gibt für Deutschland keine Zahlen, für England gibt es Zahlen und zwar im Jahre 2004 oder 2003 die britische Umweltbehörde, die British Environment Agency, also offizielle Behörde des Staates, gibt also die Zahl heraus, dass in einem Jahr zum Beispiel 500.000 Fernseher alleine exportiert worden sind an Schrott aus England, 3 Millionen Kühlschränke und 160.000 Tonnen weiterer Elektronik-Schrott und vor allem in asiatische Länder wie Indien, China und Pakistan. Und das Problem ist einfach, dass in den Ländern, in den Zielländern, wo dieser Schrott dorthin exportiert wird, da gibt es sehr wenig Bestimmungen, die das beschränken würden, dass man solchen Müll überhaupt importieren darf. Zum anderen ist es eben wie gesagt häufig als Gebrauchtware oder Spende oder so deklariert. Und zum dritten haben die halt gar nicht irgendwie das Enforcement, dass sie das am Zoll oder sonst irgendwo durchsetzen können, weil das Personal fehlt und so weiter und das Geld eben hinten und vorne. Das ist eine Riesensauerei. Und wenn natürlich dann der Elektronik-Schrott dort irgendwo verbrannt wird in irgendwelchen Hinterhöfen, dann sickern die Schwermetalle ins Wasser und dann ist das alles auch wieder äußerst gesund.
Ja, so viel zum Ableben eures PCs, wenn ihr ihn einfach so wegschmeißt. Wahrscheinlich. 03317797110 ist unsere Telefonnummer hier bei Fritz. Ihr könnt mittalken zum Thema Stromverbrauch, Energieverbrauch bei der Herstellung von so einem Teil oder bei der letztendlichen Vernichtung und vor allen Dingen auch bei euch zu Hause. Wenn ihr den denn benutzt. Der Stefan ist dran aus Berlin. Hallo Stefan.
Einen iMac G5 und ich wüsste gerne, was der so verbraucht.
So einen wassergekühlten neuen, ja?
Nee, iMac.
Ach so, iMac ist ja dann nicht stimmt. Quatsch. Ich verstand einen Mac.
Da haben wir einen G5, da ist glaube ich eine Zahl dieser Tabelle drin.
Und da schaltet sich nicht viel. Ja, Frank, schau du mal in deiner Tabelle nach.
Ich bin ja gerade am Wikipedia eine Antwort abspeichern und es dauert alles einen Augenblick, aber Wikipedia ist ja ganz schnell, wie gerade auf Golem zu lesen ist.
Wikipedia ist super schnell.
Gut, man kann generell sagen, dass die Apple Computer mit Power PC Prozessoren in den letzten Jahren vom Energieverbrauch her eigentlich vergleichbar geworden sind mit den PCs. Früher war es immer so, dass Apple viel stromsparender war als die Intel-kompatiblen PCs, von der Prozessorarchitektur her. Ja, aber insbesondere seitdem der G5 herausgekommen ist und mit den hohen Taktfrequenzen sind die also vom Stromverbrauch her relativ ähnlich. Also ich würde mal bei dem System, bei dem iMac, auch irgendwas im Bereich 200 Watt oder so...
Also ich habe hier eine Tabelle, da ist für den iMac G5 inklusive Display, haben wir hier angegeben, 100 bis 135 Watt, was eigentlich noch so im Erträglichen liegt.
Das ist erstaunlich, ja, das ist erstaunlich niedrig.
Und Zahlen zum Stromverbrauch im Standby-Modus, weil er ja auch keinen externen, also keinen Schalter hat zum richtig ausmachen.
Das ist hier nicht angegeben, aber das kannst du ja mal versuchen rauszukriegen, ruf da mal bei Apple an und sag mal Leute, wie sieht es denn eigentlich aus? Könnte mal dazu beitragen, dass sie sich da auch vielleicht Gedanken drüber machen, wenn du nicht der einzige bist, der da anruft.
Ja, vermutlich interessiert das auch noch andere.
Das war's?
Das war's.
Danke auch. Na ja, der iMac stimmt, da ist ja gar nicht so viel drin. Das sind ja relativ, muss ich sagen, kannst du ja eigentlich nur mit einem relativ schlanken PC vergleichen, ohne tausend Schnickschnacken, Steckkarten und mehreren Festplatten und so.
Ich stimme zu. Meine Axle mal husten hören. Hallo, Axle.
Ja, hallo, entschuldigt. Ja, ihr hattet gerade das Problem Leuchtstoffröhre. Leuchtstoffröhrenentsorgung. Das Problem ist, eine Leuchtstoffröhre ist eine Gasentladungsklampe. Und damit in der Gasentladungsklampe überhaupt erst mal ein Gas eckressiert, was zur Initiation angerichtet werden kann, sind da leider kleine Mengen wechselbar drin.
Ah, genau.
Das macht das Zeug relativ gefährlich beim Entsorgen. Das zweite Problem ist, dass da auch im Allgemeinen bei den verwendeten Kaltkartonen, Kaltkartode in Röhren, jetzt brach ich mir fast die Zunge dran, seltene Erden eigentlich verwendet werden, um den Leuchtstoff zu verwenden, um den Leuchtstoff herzustellen, den sollte man eventuell zurückgewinnen. Es ist aber so eine Sache, so einen LCD-Schirm kriegt man ja eigentlich nicht richtig auseinander. Das heißt, die sind industriell ja so eng zusammengebaut und so fest miteinander verbunden, dass wenn beim LCD das Backlight kaputt ist, man das Ding eigentlich wirklich nur noch entsorgen kann. Ich weiß es nicht, dass es mittlerweile schon tatsächlich sinnvolle Entsorgungsvarianten dafür gibt.
Ich glaube, das ist das Teil dieser Recycling-Richtlinie auch, dass die Sachen zumindest so zusammengebaut sein müssen, dass sie sich irgendwie trennen lassen, also dass die verschiedenen Werkstoffe voneinander getrennt werden müssen, ohne dass sie verklebt oder verschweißt sind.
Vielleicht sollte man dann aber auch, wenn man schon über das Recycling des PCs nachdenkt, eventuell darüber nachdenken, den PC möglichst lange zu nutzen. Je länger ich das Teil nutze und je weniger oft ich mir ein neues Gerät kaufen muss, desto weniger Geräte habe ich, die ich dann recyceln muss. Ich muss ja tatsächlich wirklich nicht an jeder Stelle unbedingt einen superschnellen Hyper Threading P4 oder sonst irgendwas verwenden, wenn sich viele Aufgaben eigentlich relativ mühelos auch mit einem 368er ledigen lassen. Ganz besonders und recht weit verbreitet. Das ist ja eigentlich wirklich in der Industrie. Und man verzweifelt jedes Mal daran, wenn man noch diverse Messsysteme hat, die eigentlich mühelos mit einer ISA-Karte und einem guten 468er laufen könnten. Man sich fast die Finger bricht heutzutage dafür, ein vernünftiges System zu bekommen, was das immer noch kann.
Ja, das ist also gerade im Industrie oder im Geschäftsbereich ganz extrem. Ich habe auch eine schöne Anekdote dazu. Ich habe am Flughafen München mal umgestiegen. Und da ist es tatsächlich so, dass die an jedem Gate haben, die so einen Plasma-Wildschirm oder mehrere Plasma-Wildschirme hängen.
Die sind übrigens auch heftig. So ein Plasma-Wildschirm frisst mal ganz schnell zwischen 350 und 500 Watt an.
Über den Plasma-Wildschirm wollte ich jetzt noch gar nicht reden, sondern ich wollte nur sagen, da waren mal ein paar Blue-Screens zu sehen. Die haben tatsächlich einen eigenen PC hinter jedem dieser Plasma-Wildschirme, wo ein Windows 95 oder 98 oder sowas drauf lief. Man muss also sehen, dass ein PC, und was zeigt dann dieses Display an? Das zeigt zwei grüne Punkte an, die abwechselnd blinken und die Flugnummer in weißer Schrift und das Logo der Luftlinie. Das könnte man mit einer Fernsehauflösung machen, und im C64 konnte man das vor 20 Jahren auch schon. Das setzt dann einfach aus. Jetzt haben die in München 70 Gates oder noch mehr und dann jeweils zwei oder drei Monitore mit PCs dazu.
Und dann noch der Wahnsinn, dass man überall Plasma-Schirme hinhängen muss, die ja einen derartig wahnsinnigen Stromverbrauch noch haben. Und die in diesem Betriebsmod, wie sie dort betrieben werden, ja maximal drei Jahre leben. Weil das Einbrennproblem bei den Plasma-Schirmen besteht ja immer noch. Und genau da, wo ich also nur zwei grüne Punkte und fünf verschiedene Logos anzeige, ist ja nach drei Jahren das Logo fest in der Röhre eingebrannt. Und dann kann ich ihn auch wegschmeißen. Und außerdem, wie gesagt, sind die netten Plasma-Schirme ja so, naja, die kleineren, die 42 Zolle haben so 350 Watt, die 50 Zolle sind bei 400, 440, 450 Watt, größeren sind dann bei knapp 500. Zwei Stück davon kann man relativ mühelos in sein Zimmer mithalten. Also ein bisschen sehr erschreckend. Und ich weiß nicht, ob an der Stelle wir dann wirklich sehr energieintensiv überlegen und ob das LCD-Schirme an der Stelle dann nicht auch tun würden.
Ja, da kann man eigentlich, wenn man sowas immer hört, kann man nur hoffen, dass die Energie noch deutlich teurer wird, damit Leute mal anfangen, über sowas zu denken. Außer wenn es kostet, fängt ja niemand an, darüber nachzudenken.
Das ist auch ein Problem in Firmen. Das war ja auch gerade angesprochen. Ich erlebe es bei mir auch. Also bei mir machen die Leute abends, wenn sie gehen, auch die Monitore nicht aus. Und dann laufen halt üblicherweise noch Screensaver, also Bildschirmschoner, das wäre sogar mein persönliches ganz großes Hassobjekt, weil sie nämlich verhindern, dass die Monitore ausgehen. Die gehen dann nicht in den PowerSafe-Modus, in den Stromspar-Modus. Und die CPU wird dazu noch belastet. Also es gibt ja irgendwie ganz tolle, super irgendwelche Rechenoperationen nebenbei machen, oder irgendwelche 3D-Grafikkarten belastende Bildschirmschoner noch.
Genau, denn die Grafikkarte ist auch noch anständig. Was wir tun halt, haben wir irgendeinen OpenGL Bildschirmschoner, der die Grafikkarte...
Genau, das kann also passieren, dass in dem Moment, wo ich eigentlich sage, ah prima, jetzt ist mein PC, der hat nichts zu tun, jetzt verbraucht er keinen Strom, dass er dann anfängt mehr Strom zu verbrauchen, als wenn ich eigentlich da ein Wortdokument schreibe.
Genau, das ist, glaube ich, an vielen Fällen so. Zumal ja irgendwie der Trend der Industrie dahin geht, möglichst komplexe und irre interessante Wildschirmschoner zu generieren, die dann also den PC bis an die Grenze seiner Belastungsfähigkeit auslasten.
Ja, damit auch den Stromverbrauch hochtreiben.
Damit den Stromverbrauch auch gar heftig hochtreiben, ja.
Das ist das wahre Einsatzgebiet der PCs. Das sind keine Büro-PCs, sondern das sind Dekorationsobjekte durch Wildschirmschoner.
Genau, ja, so ist es. Aber natürlich gibt es auch schon wieder die netten Streitigkeiten, ob man ein LCD ausschalten soll oder nicht. Die Lebensdauer der LCD-Röhren leidet natürlich mit Ein- und Ausschalten auch. Und es ist so eine Sache. Ich meine, die sind halt bei 50.000 Stunden Lebensdauer. Die leuchten dort hinter. Ich meine, 20.000 Stunden sind bei einer täglichen Nutzung in drei, dreieinhalb Jahren auch rum.
Ja gut, aber es wird leider wieder nicht gemacht. Aber es ist ja doch schon noch möglich. Ich persönlich kann das jetzt zumindest an den Monitoren, die ich gesehen habe, nicht nachvollziehen, dass das so verklebt werde.
Ich habe pro halber Mal versucht, einen auseinanderzunehmen, aber der ist ein relativ alter. Ich bin nicht bis zu den Leuchten vorgetrunken. Also es war richtig fest. Ich weiß nicht, ob es verklebt war. Das konnte ich an der Stelle nicht entdecken. Aber es war für mich nicht mehr sichtbar, eine Schraub- oder Klemmverbindung zu entdecken, dass man das wirklich noch bis Vortrag hat. Das ist ein relativ früher Flachbildschirm gewesen. Der ist bestimmt 5-6 Jahre alt gewesen mittlerweile. Es könnte sein, dass die tatsächlich noch wirklich verklebt waren.
Selbst für Notebooks gibt es für den entsprechenden Fachhandel und Servicehandel für Notebook-LCD-Displays auch die CCFL, also diese Kaltlichtröhren, als Ersatzteile.
Wobei billig ist es nicht, ne?
Nein, billig ist es in keinem Fall. Es ist ja auch eine relativ irre Anforderung, die ich an die Lampen stelle. Es ist ja eigentlich fast was, was sich widerspricht. Eine Leuchtstoffröhre produziert ein Linienspektrum. Und ich brauche aber, um eine möglichst echte Farbwiedergabe zu generieren, ein möglichst kontinuierliches weißes Spektrum. Ich weiß gar nicht so genau, wie das überhaupt funktioniert. Ich weiß, dass es geht. Aber ich weiß gar nicht so genau, wie man also die Leuchtstoffe jetzt so getrimmt hat, dass sie möglichst alle Farben irgendwie wiedergeben, damit man überhaupt ein einigermaßen farbrechtes Bild bekommt. Aber ich weiß auf der anderen Seite auch, dass Farbkalibrierung von LCD-Schirmen sehr komplex ist und es auch nur ganz wenige gibt, die wirklich den Farbraum darstellen können, den kompletten.
Das ist richtig, aber da schweifen wir jetzt langsam ein bisschen zu sehr ab.
Da sind wir jetzt ein ganzes Entchen weg, ja, das ist wohl wahr.
Axel, danke dir für den Anruf. Chaosradio mit Frank, Harald und Max. Ein Stündchen haben wir noch, Thema Stromverbrauch von diesem ganzen Elektronikrahmen, den wir so besitzen, insbesondere Unterhaltungs- und IT-Elektronik. Ja, also diese Geschichte mit den Ländern, in denen es produziert wird, wie es produziert wird, dass das da schon Stromverbrauch kostet. Das hat, glaube ich, den Sebastian aus Berlin-Cherlottenburg angestiftet, mal anzurufen. Hallo Sebastian.
Mir kommen die Tränen bei diesem Thema. Und zwar aber eher, wie es dargestellt wird, weil dieser Pessimismus, der hier wieder verbreitet wird, das ist wirklich grauenvoll. Natürlich ist es eine Problematik, aber die gibt es doch seit 20 Jahren, schon mindestens seit 25 Jahren, genauso wie die heutigen aktuellen Meldungen, irgendwie Rußpartikelfilter oder hier die ganze Staubbelastung. Das ist doch alles wirklich ein altes Thema. Das wird irgendwie hervorgeholt. Und dann macht man hier kollektiv irgendwie, bläst man wieder Trübsal, in Taiwan, in China lachen die Leute über sowas, über diese ganze Problematik, die hier zu einer Stagnation in der Wirtschaft führt. Ich will damit nicht sagen, dass diese Themen nicht wichtig sind, aber diese ganze Diskussion, die auch mit dem Hörer zuvor da war, das ist auch lächerlich, weil nach drei Jahren sind Monitore technisch überholt oder wesentlich verbessert worden. Das heißt, jeder tauscht das aus. Das Beispiel mit dem Flughafen München, mit dem PC, da wird irgendwie wieder was hervorgekramt. Die Ansteuerung von einem Plastma-Bildschirm, das ist auch völliger Unsinn, weil diese Gates teilweise individuell angesteuert werden müssen durch Veränderungen des Flugzeuges, das an das Gate fährt. Es gibt oft Verschiebungen. Das heißt, es gibt eine Notwendigkeit dafür. Hier wird also in meiner Ansicht nach ein Pessimismus wieder in Deutschland hier verbreitet durch diese Sendung. Das ist grauenvoll. Ein weiteres Beispiel, umweltpolitisch, Chrome zum Beispiel. Chrome wurde auch vor 20, 25 Jahren schon diskutiert, dass es dem Ende zugeht. Heute Autokeufer achten, das sind nur noch Beispiele, dass Leute sagen, ich kaufe ein Auto, was sehr chromebehaftet ist. Das heißt, Käuferverhalten steht sehr im Vordergrund. Wir können jetzt hier lange philosophieren über Themen, aber diese Stagnation, dieser Pessimismus, der durch alle möglichen Medien läuft, ist grauenvoll in China, Taiwan, ich habe beruflich sehr viel damit zu tun, bin oft in diesen Ländern. Da lachen die Leute inzwischen drüber.
Ja, das mag ja sein, dass die Leute dort lachen, nur wenn die auch früher oder später mit den Folgen zu kämpfen haben, dessen, was sie denn tun mit ihrer Umwelt im Moment.
Ja, aber was sollen wir in Deutschland machen? Pardon, wir sind eine Wirtschaftsnation. Und immer diese jegliche Meldung, jegliche Sendung inzwischen, immer nur mit Pessimismus überzogen. Das sind doch Themen, die nicht neu sind.
Ja gut, aber wir sind eine Wirtschaftsnation. Wirtschaft und Wirtschaften, das ist in Deutschland ja nicht so hundertprozentig eins. Also es ist ja nicht unbedingt wirtschaftlich, sich alle zwei Jahre ein neues Handy kaufen zu müssen. Natürlich kurbelt das die Wirtschaft an. Nein, nein, nein, aua, aua, aua, aua.
Die ganzen Fritz-Hörer kaufen doch kein monochromes Display mehr für Handys, die ganzen Kids 14, 15 Jahre alt. Die werden doch nie auf dem Schulhof irgendwie sein und kaufen sich ein Handy, was nur, was kein Colors-Twin hat.
Ja, aber ich würde also diese Korrelation zwischen einerseits dem Konsumentenverhalten und andererseits der Wirtschaft, die ja im Grunde diese Sachen anbietet. Es ist ja nicht so, als würde der Konsument die ganze Zeit diesen Druck machen. Das ist ja ein hin und her schwappendes Verhältnis, was sich da ergibt. Und die Frage ist, wie geht die Wirtschaft das an? Natürlich ist es der Wirtschaft unbequem, bestimmte Sachen mit einzubauen, zu sagen, hey, hier, Bildschirme zum Beispiel. Irgendwann wurde den Leuten klar, oh, wenn ich die ganze Zeit von den Bildschirmen sitze, dann geht es mir schlecht. Und dann haben die angefangen, Strahlungsklassen einzuführen und bestimmte Grenzwerte einzuführen, damit du eben nicht die ganze Zeit hier rüber vollstrahlst, immer Kopfschmerzen kriegst oder schlechte Augen und Ähnliches. Also das ist ja auch, es geht ja auch um Bedürfnisse. Und welche Bedürfnisse werden geschaffen, damit du quasi der Wirtschaft auch von Nutzen bis in dem du kaufst und welche Bedürfnisse werden einfach nicht geschaffen, weil sie der Wirtschaft nicht gut tun würden?
Das sehe ich anders, weil die Leute, Phänomien Chibo zum Beispiel, Leute kaufen nach einem Preis, kaufen irgendwie jeden Schrott, der bei Chibo verkauft wird. Das sind Erzeugnisse, die großenteils gerade in China natürlich gefertigt werden, zu einem unglaublichen Preis. Und auch mit dem, da fragt keiner, wo die Sachen herkommen, ob die Strahlungsarmen sind gut. Über Monitoro brauchen wir nicht mehr zu reden. Es geht um Flachbildschirme, die sind natürlich strahlungsfrei. Aber da fragt auch kein Mensch mehr, wo das herkommt, sondern das Preisdiktat, Media Markt, Chibo, sonst was. Wir können auch andere Hersteller noch nennen oder Vertriebskanäle. Das Problem ist doch wirklich jetzt nicht zu sagen, die Wirtschaft ist daran schuld, sondern der Konsument ist einfach daran schuld, weil er billig kauft, ja, all die Phänomene. Das ist doch genau das Problem, in dem wir leben. Und man kann doch nicht sagen, irgendwie, es gab Designpreise für bestimmte Produkte in den letzten Jahren, gab es Extrakategorien für die Bewertung, ob die Stand-By-Modus haben, wo sehr wenig Strom oder vielleicht sogar gar kein Strom durchfließt, gab es Designpreise, es war ein Kriterium dafür für Geräte. Das ist alles inzwischen wieder weg, weil es nicht honoriert wird vom Markt. Da kann man doch nicht sagen, irgendwie, die Wirtschaft ist fast schuld. Ich greife wirklich sichtbar den Konsumenten an, weil die noch einen Preis haben.
Der Strom ist zu billig.
Ja, dann ist es aber, nein, wenn ich an der Stelle das einbringen darf, dann ist unsere Sendung genau das Richtige, um vielleicht das Bedürfnis bei dem Verbraucher zu wecken, dass er vielleicht in Zukunft mal doch die eine oder andere Kaufentscheidung anders treffen könnte.
Ja, das ist sehr richtig. Ich will ja nicht die Sendung an, aber ich will diesen Pessimismus wirklich angreifen, weil das Problem ist doch wirklich, ein bestes Beispiel, Handys. Ich habe es eben gesagt, mit den ganzen Kids, die Kids lachen sich doch auf dem Schulhof, lachen doch denjenigen aus, der irgendwie noch ein Handy hat, mit einem einfachen Display, also monochrom, also einfarbig jetzt für alle anderen, also die jetzt da nicht ganz firm sind. Und ein Color Screen, das ist jetzt ein Must für die ganzen Kids und die kaufen das. Und was weiß ich, das ist halt das Konsumverhalten. Die Wirtschaft würde gerne noch irgendwie weiter, weil es gibt Halden voll mit einfarbigen Displays, die ganzen Fabriken sind darauf noch ausgerichtet, gibt es für einen unglaublich billigen Preis, aber heute kann man kein Handy, zumindest in Europa, mehr verkaufen, was kein Color Screen hat. So, damit fängt es an, damit wird ein Begehren natürlich erwägt von der Wirtschaft, kann man wieder sagen, die Wirtschaft ist schuld, aber der Konsument sagt irgendwie, ich kaufe es, und hänselt dann den Mitschüler, der jetzt keinen Color Screen hat.
Die Vollerisation, die du betreibst zwischen der Wirtschaft und dem Konsumenten, anders als die haben wir in der Sendung ja aber eigentlich gar nicht betrieben. Also wir haben das ja nur allgemein als Problem beschrieben und haben noch mal gar nicht irgendwie gesagt, da wäre jemand dran schuld, sondern wir haben einfach nur beschrieben, dass es ein Problem hier existiert und dass es eigentlich mal Zeit wäre, nachzudenken über dieses Problem.
Ja, aber das ist doch kein Thema, das irgendwie jetzt neu wäre. Das ist genauso mit diesen, deswegen sage ich, mit diesen Rußpartikelfiltern, das ist doch ein Thema, braucht man nur irgendwelche Zeitschriften oder Zeitungen von 1980 aufzublättern, da ist genau diese Krebsgefahr von Diesel-Abgasen absolut schon nachweislich.
Ja, umso wichtiger ist es doch ständig, immer wieder darauf aufmerksam zu sein.
Ja, ich sage nicht, das ist falsch. Ja, aber es wird doch, es ist irgendwie blind zu sagen, irgendwie zu behaupten, wir gehen das Thema mal an mit Stand-by-Modus. Es wird doch zunehmen. Die ganze Geschichte, und da greife ich auch mit den Konsumenten an oder wie auch immer, das wird doch zunehmen jetzt mit den Gebühren für Telefonanschlüsse. Es wird ein harter Wettbewerb werden für Voice-over-IP, also das heißt, dass man übers Internet telefoniert. Das heißt, da braucht man eigentlich, um wirklich das richtig einzusetzen, auch als Privatkonsument, 24 Stunden online, dass der Computer dann an ist. So wird das in der Zukunft sein.
Dafür fällt die Vermittlungsstelle weg.
Ja, aber das heißt ja einfach, dass ein Gerät 24 Stunden einfach an ist.
Grundsätzlich, Sebastian, glaube ich, dass du das, was wir hier als Thema ausgelegt haben, vielleicht ein bisschen falsch geschluckt hast. Ich würde das nicht als Pessimismus bezeichnen. Es geht einfach im Chaosradio immer darum, ein bisschen wieder was ins Bewusstsein zu rücken. Es ist ja nicht so, als würden wir drei, die wir hier sitzen, keine PCs besitzen, keine Handys besitzen. Wir sind die absoluten Geeks. Wir kaufen uns jeden Scheiß, ja. Und wir wissen auch ganz genau, wenn ich jetzt hier sitze, muss ich auch mit mir klarkommen, dass das wahrscheinlich irgendein kleiner 14-Jähriger zusammengelötet hat, or whatever. Da geht es nicht um Pessimismus. Es geht nur darum, dass natürlich dieses Bewusstsein, das wir hier schaffen, unbequem ist. Natürlich ist das scheiße, wenn du reinkommst in die Wohnung und du musst auf einmal wieder über Sachen nachdenken, die die Industrie eigentlich schon längst abgenommen hat. Ja, Stand-by ist ja dazu da, damit du deinen Scheiß-Video-Recorder nicht ausmachen musst. Aber wenn du auf einmal wieder merkst, oh, ich muss wieder was ausmachen, das kostet Zeit, das kostet Gedanken, die du daran verschwendest, das ist unbequem. Das wissen wir auch. Uns geht es nicht um Pessimismus. Es geht nur darum, so eine Art von Bewusstsein zwischendurch wieder zu schaffen, dass das, was Chaosradio eigentlich immer macht, mal zwischendurch auf Sachen blicken, die vielleicht es schon gab, die vielleicht einfach vergessen waren, die noch niemand gesehen hat. Und das finde ich ganz legitim, das kann man auch mal machen. Pessimisten sind wir eigentlich nie gewesen. Nein, das glaube ich nicht.
Also ich glaube schon mal deswegen, die haben Rufa gezeigt.
Die Maschen nimmt das zwar nicht wahr, das ist doch das Problem.
Sind wir eine massentaugliche Sendung oder sind wir ein... Wollen wir das sein?
Also wir probieren immer so eine Art von halber halber Ding zu machen zwischen Freaks und den Leuten, die wir vielleicht ins Boot holen können, die sich jetzt sagen, wenn der Sebastian da auch so bei der Sache ist und das so ein Herzblut für den ist und der möchte mal sagen, wir seien pessimistisch, man hört einfach zu. Und ich glaube, es ist eine andere Wartungsweise, damit umzugehen. Ich glaube, dass du sowas nicht mainstream-fähig machen kannst. Das hat die Wirtschaft begriffen, weil die Wirtschaft muss nach dem Prinzip mainstream agieren, deswegen macht sie das natürlich auch nicht. Aber das ist eine Sinnfrage und das ist eine Metaebene und ich glaube, damit haben wir beide unsere Argumentationen hier alle vorgebracht, unsere Partei da in einem Podcast.
Okay, aber was mir wichtig ist, dass auch wirklich nicht nur die Wirtschaft, das meine ich mit Pessimismus, dass die Wirtschaft nicht allein angegriffen wird, sondern wirklich der träge Konsument und das ist der Massenkonsument, nicht vielleicht jetzt der Fritzhörer, der jetzt diese Sendung hört oder sowas, aber all die Phänomen, das Gleiche, Lidl, ausstärken von irgendwelchen Fachgeschäften oder auch Leute, die wirklich beraten, die Masse ist träger, das ist das Problem.
Wohl wahr.
Dagegen kämpfen wir an.
Sebastian, danke für den Anruf.
Viertel nach, also drei Optimisten im Studio hier bei Fritz Chaosradio, Thema Stromverbrauch und der nächste in der Leitung ist der Markus aus Berlin Steglitz. Hallo Markus.
Hallo und Abend. Ich wollte noch mal zu meinem Vorgehender sagen, also zum Beispiel hat er so Rußpartikel angeführt, da wollte ich nur mal sagen, dass aufgrund neuer Diesel-Technologie und besserer Katalysatoren oder Verbrennungsmechanismen, sag ich mal, der dieser Staub so fein geworden ist, diese Partikel, dass sie durch die Rußfälle, die es jetzt auch mal gab, für die Diesel davor, nicht mehr so funktionieren und da halt neue her müssen. Das ist halt nicht so, dass das seit Jahren bekannt ist. Das hat sich jetzt einfach eingeschlichen. Jetzt haben irgendwelche Europäer irgendwas, sag ich mal, beschlossen politisch. Und jetzt müssen wir uns an Diesel-Grenzwerte scheinbar halten. Und da sagen wir alle so, oh, was ist jetzt besser, so bessere Verbrennungen von Diesel oder ja dann doch Rußpartikel dadurch, wo die Leute dann wieder Krebs kriegen.
Ich habe es heute Nachmittag schon mal geschaut, Feinstoff wird das Wort des Jahres 2005.
Aber es ist aber auch natürlich bei Rechnern so. Das heißt also alle Gesetze, alle Vorschriften, die gemacht werden, sind selten vorausschauend, sondern reflektieren immer nur das, was gerade passiert, irgendwelche Trends und so was und haben deswegen gerade in so einer schnell wandelnden Technologie immer nur wenig Bestand.
Ja, ich wollte noch mal ganz kurz auch dieses Lachen in Asien, das fand ich ein bisschen blöd, weil erstmal sind die Buden jetzt erstmal völlig hoch und irgendwann, denke ich, müssen wir uns alle darüber Gedanken machen, woher wir die Rohstoffe nehmen und die werden natürlich immer teurer, weil die immer weniger werden. Auch so Aufarbeitung muss dann auch irgendwie besser werden, aber im Endeffekt sitzen wir alle dann irgendwann in einem Boot und haben halt irgendwie keine Teile mehr. Also ich denke halt zum Beispiel, wenn jemand zu Hause einen Rechner einen ganzen Tag laufen lassen will, macht er meistens Tauschbörse oder Downloads oder irgendwas ähnliches, also so der Normaluser. Und dazu sollte man halt einfach vielleicht einen älteren Rechner benutzen. Ich hab mir so einen älteren zusammengebaut, einen Gigahertz, so Adgon von damals, der zieht halt auch schon ganz schön viel. Aber dann halt so bei der Grafikkarte, eine vielleicht mal einfach ohne Lüfter, eine ältere GeForce MX reicht völlig aus. Und dann hat man vielleicht schon ja 20 Prozent weniger Stromverbrauch dadurch oder vielleicht sogar, weil die Grafikkarten brauchen ja heute auch 100, damals waren es 20, 30, je nachdem, was das war. Und da würde ich halt auch einfach mal sagen, dass man drüber nachdenkt, einfach, wenn man sowas machen will, so einen älteren Rechner zu verwenden. Und es gibt ja viele Leute, die auch so was loswerden wollen und ich hab selber gelernt, so ein bisschen besser damit umzugeben, einen Rechner länger zu behalten, auch wenn er technologisch nicht mehr so on top ist, aber dass man halt einfach so ein bisschen sorgsamer damit umgeht und nicht einfach irgendwie dann wegschmeißt oder, ja man kann halt immer noch was draus machen, sag ich mal.
Mir zuckt es ja auch mal regelmäßig mal in den Fingern, wo ich irgendwie sage, na, vielleicht mal was Neues, mein Rechner ist jetzt schon zweieinhalb Jahre alt und so, aber hey, wozu?
Ich denke, also ich mach das so, ich hab selber halt diesen langsamen Rechner für die Tauschbörse, der ist den ganzen Tag an oder halt um E-Mails einfach nur zu empfangen, immer da zu sein und der andere Rechner ist halt ein 2, 6 Kilohertz Rechner, der dann immer angeschaltet wird, wenn ich wirklich zu Hause bin und den auch benutze, weil selber, wenn ich halt ausrunde fliege, der braucht halt einen Rechner, der schon wenigstens drei Viertel der Zeitleistung so hat und halt noch schon die etwas besseren, cooleren Spiele halt noch so gerade so zocken kann, das traf ich halt auch besser, also das muss halt schon so ein bisschen was besseres halt sein, was man so zur Verfügung hat als Technik, aber so ein Rechner muss man nicht den ganzen Tag laufen lassen. Ich hab einen Freund, der hat einen 3 Gigahertz Rechner, hat sich total gefreut, aber toll, Tauschbörse läuft super, sein Rechner ist um 50 Prozent lockiert, der kann sonst nichts damit machen und der frisst halt einfach nur Strom.
Eine Frage vielleicht noch für dich zum Abschluss und zwar, wie viel Prozent des gesamten deutschen Stromverbrauchs denkst du geht für das Internet und die Unterhaltungselektronik drauf?
Naja, nicht viel Prozent, also ich müsste jetzt wissen, wie viele Leute durchschnittlichen Rechner haben oder so, ich denke schon, dass es…
Was meinst du damit für das Internet?
Also alles so Server und sowas.
Ja, sämtliche Server, die Netzwerkeinfrastruktur, alle PCs, die irgendwo so rumstehen und laufen.
Ich denke schon, dass es so irgendwas zwischen 30-40 Prozent sein könnte.
Nee, so extrem ist es Gott sei Dank noch nicht. Ja, wir haben da auch wieder unterschiedlichste Zahlen. In den USA liegt es wohl mittlerweile bei 13 Prozent. In Deutschland, wenn man die Unterhaltungselektronik nicht mit rein nimmt, sondern nur Computer, Internet und dergleichen, gibt es also Schätzungen, die irgendwie zwischen 3-5 teilweise bis 8 Prozent gehen. Wobei 3-5 Prozent sicherlich die realistischere und die glaubenswürdigeren Zahlen sind.
Wobei, ich glaube nicht, dass man den Stromverbrauch an sich beim normalen User so rauskriegen würde prozentual, weil der verbraucht ja eine gewisse Menge im Monat und da weiß man nicht, wie es aufgespitzt ist. Also da wird wahrscheinlich auch noch eine Menge prozent für draufgehen.
Na ja, es gibt ja durchaus Umfragen und Statistiken und wie lange PC-Sympflovataushalten genutzt werden und so weiter und so weiter, also ich denke, da kann man schon danach gehen, dass diese Zahlen irgendwo zumindest in der Größenordnung richtig liegen. Also wenn jetzt hier die Studien ergeben, das würden irgendwie 3 bis 5% sein, dann sind es nicht 20 oder 30, also so viel daneben, wenn sie nicht liegen.
Ich würde mal sagen, im Hardwarebereich ist es sowieso so, dass die jetzt erkannt haben, wir machen jetzt nicht mehr 3 Gigahertz, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8, 9, 10, sondern wir machen dann also nochmal 2 CPUs und eine 64-Bit und sowas, da denke ich schon, es geht so ein bisschen in eine bessere Richtung, wobei ich halt zu Hause empfehlen würde, also wenn ich das Geld hätte, würde ich mir sofort ein Notebook-Mainboard für ein RTX-Kohle holen und mir so ein 2-Gigahertz-Teil raufknallen, das hat genauso viel Power mit dem 2-MegaWatt-Level-2-Cache wie, was weiß ich, ein Athlon 64 oder vergleichbar Pentium mit 3 Gigahertz.
Na, dass die Entwicklung an der Stelle nicht mehr weitergeht in höhere Geschwindigkeiten, das hängt einfach damit zusammen, dass man echte Probleme hat, das weiter zu treiben.
Die haben jetzt so und so viele Nanometern, die gehen immer weiter runter, aber irgendwann ist da eine Grenze erreicht, auch prinzipiell.
Na, es sind tatsächlich schon andere Probleme, mit denen man kämpft. Es ist tatsächlich darum geht, dass die Geschwindigkeit, wie lang so ein Elektron braucht, um in dem Chip von einer Ecke in die andere zu kommen, also endlich ist. Und da hat man dann Probleme, dass sozusagen das Signal noch nicht angekommen ist am Ziel, wenn man das nächste schon wieder abschicken will.
Da muss neue Technologie her, denke ich. Aber im Quantencomputer-Bereich braucht man noch mehr.
Aber jetzt energietechnisch hilft uns das natürlich nichts, wenn die Leute zwei oder vier Vorzessonen in ihren Rechner reinstecken. Die brauchen zwei oder viermal so viel Strom. Da kommen wir also auch nicht weiter.
Ich denke, da wären wirklich so Konzepte, wie dass man halt wirklich ein Rechner hat, mit dem man dann wirklich die härteren Sachen so erledigt, aber dann nicht halt 24 Stunden lang, die Inhalte nicht extra anlässt und halt die anderen Sachen mit so vielleicht einfach noch mal energiesparenden Sachen oder sich mal ein paar geschickte Kombinationen überlegt. Das erwarte ich jetzt auch von der Industrie, dass die Energiepreise steigen, durch Ressourcen bedingt schon alleine. Und irgendwann, denke ich mal, wird sich das auch selber regulieren, weil man kann sich das gar nicht mehr leisten, zwei Rechner einen ganzen Tag anzuhaben oder einen. Da hat ja jeder, denke ich mal, in letzter Zeit so ordentlich Preiserhöhungen erfahren von der jeweiligen Energiegesellschaft.
Ja, bis das ankommt, wird es wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen dauern, aber die Rechnung ist auf jeden Fall klar.
Ganz kurz noch, PSPs zum Vorvorredner, da wollte ich nur sagen, es gibt ja jetzt eine neue Technologie schon, diese mit den LED-Visionen, die ja jetzt viel mehr Farben darstellen können, 60.000 Stunden halten, das sind dann schon einfach mal mehr als drei Jahre, so ungefähr acht oder so, keine Ahnung. Und dadurch halt auch die Brillanz von Röhrenmonitoren endlich erreicht wird, die dann wahrscheinlich wirklich komplett aussterben. Aber da gibt es halt auch schon das nächste, und zu Plasma wollte ich sagen, wer sich so was kauft für einen Rechner oder so, oder wo man vielleicht mal ein Standbild hat. Das ist ja für SwiftPay bei jedem Plasma- oder Rückstrahlprojekt irgendwie nicht so gut. Und das würde ich mir sowieso nicht kaufen, da würde ich auf die gleich großen TFTs warten, die dann, denke ich mal, auch preiswerter sind.
Ja, da bist du andere eine Nase voraus. Die müssen die Erfahrung erst noch machen.
Eine interessante Umwelt. Sauerei sind übrigens auch die ganzen Werbe-CDs. Ihr kennt die bestimmt, die sind in Zeitschriften aufgeklebt, liegen einfach so in Briefkasten. Es gibt so eine Zahl von ungefähr 30 Milliarden CDs pro Jahr, die hergestellt werden. Vielleicht sind es 20, vielleicht sind es auch 40, aber sind in der Größenordnung einfach Milliarden. Also es ist einfach unglaublich, was irgendwie da an CDs rausgehauen wird. Und ein großer Teil davon sind Werbe-CDs, viele Rohlinge natürlich auch. Und mit dem Recycling sieht es also nicht so doll aus. Also man kann die normalen CDs ganz gut recyceln, wenn sie dann auch tatsächlich mal sinnvoll gesammelt werden, systematisch gesammelt werden und verwertet werden. Wo passiert das denn bitte? Also ich glaube, bei AOL gab es mal so eine schöne Aktion, wo die Leute, die gesammelt haben und denen, die dann vor der Tür abgekippt haben.
Na du kannst sogar bei AOL ganz offiziell, das ist ein Angebot von AOL, darfst du die UN-frei zurücksenden, die Werbe-CDs an AOL und dann würden die einem ordnungsgemäßen Recycling zugeführt. Bei der Telekom gibt es das Angebot, dass du die in den T-Punkten abgeben kannst, was natürlich ein bisschen aufwendig ist irgendwie. Es ist wohl eher eine Werbemaßnahme, um die Leute in den T-Punkt zu locken, als das, was mit Recycling zu tun hätte. Aber es ist tatsächlich so, dass das Polycarbonat, also diese glasichte Kunststoff, aus dem die CDs besteht, den kann man sehr gut recyceln und der kann noch als Rohstoff für zum Beispiel die Autoindustrie verwendet werden, nach anderen Bereichen. Das ist tatsächlich nur ein Problem des Entsorgens. Vielleicht haben wir ja in fünf Jahren neben der blauen Tonne und der gelben Tonne und so weiter noch eine Tonne für CDs dazu, wer weiß.
Genau, es nützt nämlich nichts, die in die gelbe Tonne zu werfen, weil die sind keine Verpackung und werden aussortiert und gehen auch wieder in den Müll. Der Benny ist am Telefon.
Ich wollte mal ganz kurz, bevor ich zu dem, was ich eigentlich sagen wollte, kommen, sagen zu dem, ich glaube, vorletzten Redner, zu dem Pessimismus. Also ich bin der Meinung, dass es ganz, ganz wichtig ist, den Leuten das mal ein bisschen bewusst zu machen, was da eigentlich passiert in Sachen Stromverbrauch, weil wenn ich das zum Beispiel sehe, hier bei einer Freundin, da läuft dann der ganze Tag den Rechner, um irgendwelche MP3s abzuspielen, da ist ein 2, 4 Gigahertz Rechner oder irgendwie sowas und ja, im Endeffekt wird ein bisschen solitär gespielt und Musik gehört. Und ich meine, wir, sage ich jetzt mal, die Leute, die sich mit Computern auskennen und die da dann doch immer zu den Leuten gehen und bei den Problemchen helfen, wir sind ja eigentlich die ersten, die erstmal ein bisschen darauf aufmerksam gemacht werden müssen, um das dann weitergeben zu können, also insofern halte ich das nicht für einen Passivismus, der da gemacht wird, man muss da einfach mal ein bisschen drüber nachdenken.
Ja eben, also gerade auch jetzt dieses Beispiel mit dem MP3 abspielen, da kann man ja auch darauf verweisen, dass es ja durchaus eine ganze Reihe von Geräten gibt, also die mobilen MP3-Player oder auch Geräte, die man sich so auf die Stereoanlage stellen kann, die deutlich weniger Strom verbrauchen, als irgendwie so ein Standalone-PC das tut, also wirklich um den Faktor 50, sage ich mal, oder so, kann man da tatsächlich in dem Punkt Strom sparen. Und das ist ja im Gegenteil wieder was, was die Wirtschaft ankurbelt, weil sie uns diese Geräte extra noch verkaufen kann, zusätzlich zu den PCs, die wir eh schon daheim stehen haben.
Ja, bei ganz vielen ist es ja so, die holen sich dann den neuesten Aldi-PC, sind stolz wie Oscar und dann schreiben sie irgendwie drei Word-Dokumente und eine Excel-Datei im Jahr und hören halt eine MP3. Aber gut, das wollte ich eigentlich gar nicht sagen. Mir ist nämlich das mit diesem Stromverbrauch in den letzten Tagen auch so richtig bewusst geworden. Ich habe zu Hause so einen kleinen Server, das ist ein P2 450, der tut seit einiger Zeit gut seinen Dienst, seit bestimmt schon zwei Jahren oder so. Das Problem ist, dass der nun ein bisschen, also das System ist veraltet und ich will an denen nicht rumpummeln, weil ich weiß das ganz genau, wenn man am Freitagabend anfängt, ist man Montagmorgen nicht fertig und das läuft nicht wieder. Also habe ich mir gedacht, setze ich ein zweites System parallel auf, bis das läuft und dann wird halt getauscht. Da hatte ich zur Auswahl einmal einen Atlon 1, 2 GHz oder einen Celeron mit 2, 4 GHz. Na ja gut, dachte ich, ist natürlich der Atlon, der verbraucht weniger Strom.
Ja, nee, weit gefehlt.
Ich habe gemessen, der Atlon verbraucht, also mit einer Festzatte drin, ich weiß nicht, irgendwie eine 80 GB Festzatte oder so, keiner tollen Grafikkarte, 100 Watt im Leerlauf, ohne Last. Der Celeron mit 2, 4 GHz, auch ähnlich, auch keine dicke Grafikkarte oder so, braucht nur 50 Watt. Gut, da ist die Entscheidung klar. Es wundert mich zwar, von der Wärmeentwicklung merkt man es ganz klar, der Atlon, das war ja gerade diese Generation, wo sie alle wahnsinnige thermische Probleme hatten und die Lüfter nicht groß genug sein konnten und alle rumgestöhnt haben.
Ja, AMD hatte lange Zeit und hat auch bis heute keine so sehr gute Position, wenn man es irgendwie vom Energieverbrauch her beurteilt. Also ich persönlich bin eigentlich schon recht angetan von dem, was sie immer so wieder herausbringen, jetzt aus der Performance-Seite und so weiter, aber Energieverbrauchstechnisch betrachtet das AMD leider nicht so, wie man sich das wünschen würde. Eine interessante Zahl vielleicht noch für, wenn du ja doch auch ein bisschen technischer bist und jetzt auch mal ein bisschen gemessen hast mit den Prozessoren, vielleicht mal kurz die chronologische Entwicklungen, 80386 hat 1 Watt maximal Abgabeleistung gehabt, so wie herauskam der erste, der 486er 3 Watt, beim Pentium waren es schon 15, beim P2 35, beim P4 65, bis jetzt heute die High-End-Modelle irgendwo knapp über 100, 110, mittlerweile 120 teilweise und der Oberhammer für mich, der persönliche in puncto Stromverbrauch bei Prozessoren ist der IBM Power 5, das ist so ein High-End-Prozessor, der in so Großrechnern eingebaut wird und der hat tatsächlich eine Verlustleistung von um die 500 Watt. Und das auf der Größe, das ist ungefähr so groß wie eine dreieinhalb Zoll Diskette und auf dieser Fläche entwickelt er diese Verlustleistung. IBM, also ich habe mich da mit einem der Prozessorentwickler bei IBM unterhalten und der meinte, ja, ach, das wäre alles noch kein Problem, so von der Hitze abfuhr in den Rechnern, das mit der Kühlung würden sie alles hinbekommen, das ist also nicht das Problem. Ganz im Gegenteil, sie haben jetzt sogar was noch mit eingebaut, wo sie dann, ich glaube, es waren 37 Temperatursensoren auf dem Prozessor mit haben. Und du kannst den Kühlkörper abnehmen und dir drosseln den dann automatisch so langsam runter, dass die Temperatur noch passt. Also die machen den Prozessor dann genau so, dass er so viel Abwärme erzeugt, wie gerade eben abgeführt werden kann.
Ja, ich denke auch gerade so, also ich meine bei den Laptops, da ist es ja nun schon so, dass die die Tagsfrequenz einstellen, dass die dann runter regeln, um Strom zu sparen. So ist bei großen Rechnern, ich weiß nicht, gibt es da schon sowas?
Ich bin also jetzt bei normalen Desktop-PCs selten. Selten. Wie gesagt, es kommt, also wir hatten es vorhin schonmal kurz angeschnitten, es kommt jetzt langsam, also es gibt die ersten Desktop- und auch Serverprozessoren, die jetzt entsprechende Funktionen mitbringen. Bei ein Prozessorsystem ist doch alles gar nicht so kritisch. Schlimm wird es bei mehr Prozessorsystemen, weil wenn die dann die zwei Prozessoren oder die mehrere mit unterschiedlicher Tagsfrequenz laufen, das gibt dann wieder ganz eigenartige Effekte, da kann man das wieder nicht mehr brauchen. Das erstößt man dann wieder an andere Probleme.
Eine Frage habe ich noch.
Klar.
Und zwar, ich habe, wie gesagt, ich bin jetzt beim Serveraufbau und ich habe mich jetzt nur halt für den Celeron mit 2, 4 Gigahertz entschieden, klar, zugunsten der Stromrechnung. Ja, nur habe ich die ganzen Festplatten eingebaut, also es sind ja dann doch immer mehrere Festplatten.
Wenn man einen Server macht, dann ist der ja auch Fileserver und dann muss da ja immer ein bisschen was rein.
Und da bin ich nur doch wieder auf 100 Watt gekommen. Also es sind 5 Festplatten, die drin sind. Und ja, nur habe ich mal geguckt, wenn ich die abschalte, in Standby-Modus fahre, dann ist er wieder bei meinen 50 Watt oder 60 oder irgendwie so. Die Sache ist ja nur, dass ich gehört habe, dass IDE, also sind IDE Festplatten, dass die das ja nicht so gerne mögen, wenn man die immer an und ausschaltet.
Weil im Endeffekt, wie ist es?
Der Rechner läuft zwar immer, macht sowas wie Mails abholen oder jetzt Tauschbörse, was der Vorredner auch meinte. Aber im Endeffekt an die vielen Festplatten, an die großen Daten, muss ich eigentlich ja relativ selten ran. Die laufen halt immer vor sich hin und...
Benni, jetzt kommen wir auf den Punkt.
Ja, den Punkt hatten wir ja schon. Wir hatten das auch vorhin schon am Anfang der Sendung mal angeschnitten. Das heißt also so, dass egal, welche Festplatten das jetzt sind, die mögen das nie, wenn sie sonderlich oft allen ausgeschaltet werden. Also das verkürzt die Lebenszeit der Lager deutlich. Es ist also tatsächlich eine Abwägung, die man treffen muss und das ist, ja, schlecht.
Ich habe zum Beispiel gesehen, also als ich die runtergefahren habe, gut, das ist jetzt ein Lidungssystem mit HD-Palm, da habe ich gesehen, dass es ein Parameter gibt, dass man den Samsung Stromsparmodus ausschaltet für die Festplatte. Machen die das im Endeffekt auch so, dass die die Drehzahl drosseln, wenn die so einen Stromsparmodus haben, weil dann ist es ja nicht richtig aus. Das war nicht direkt ein Stand-by-Modus.
Also den Samsung-Stromsparmodus sagt mir jetzt nichts, der Begriff, dass die Geschwindigkeit gedrosselt wird, gibt es nicht. Die Platten drehen immer mit hoher Geschwindigkeit oder sie werden dann abgeschalten, aber dass die Geschwindigkeit gedrosselt wird, gibt es nicht. Was es gibt bei Festplatten mittlerweile ist Acoustic-Management, dass man die Festplatten leiser konfigurieren kann. Aber wir haben jetzt Nachrichtenzeit. Danke für dein Anruf.
Benni, Spaß beim Bauen.
Wenn Fritz rundum hält sich, dann 91, 9.
0 Uhr 35. Na lieber Scholli, ja, Wetter sieht gut aus, paar Wolken, kein Regen, die Tiefstwerte liegen zwischen plus zwei und minus zwei Grad, der Donnerstag nebelig, Anfangs aber nur, später wird es dann schön mit viel Sonne und wenig Wolken, Höchsttemperatur liegen zwischen neun und zwölf Grad. Jetzt die Meldung und Matthias Kerkhoff.
Entschuldigung. Das Umweltministerium in Potsdam befürchtet, dass die Grenzwerte der Europäischen Union für Feinstaub in diesem Jahr auch in mehreren Brandenburger Städten überschritten werden könnten. An erster Stelle gelte dies für Cottbus, Frankfurt und Bernau. Über Fahrverbote werde aber derzeit nicht nachgedacht, hieß es. Bundeskanzler Schröder will die Aufhebung des EU-Waffenembargues gegen China in jedem Fall durchsetzen. Er wird in dieser Frage selbst ein Nein der Bundesregierung ignorieren, sagte Schröder der Wochenzeitung Die Zeit. Vor der Westküste der indonesischen Insel Sumatra hat am Abend erneut die Erde gebebt. Das Nachbeben hatte eine Stärke von 6, 3, wie der geologische Dienst der USA erklärte. Berichte über Verletzte oder Schäden liegen momentan nicht vor. In Tschechien ist die sozial-liberale Koalition und der Ministerpräsident Gross zusammengebrochen. Die Christdemokraten beschlossen, sich aus dem seit 2002 amtierenden Bündnis zurückzuziehen.
Das bestgekleidete Fußballteam zwischen Elbe und Oda ist wieder unterwegs. Auf den schönsten Fußballplätzen in Berlin und Brandenburg. Wer das Fritz-Zockerteam schlägt, darf die total schicken Fritz-Trikots von Adidas behalten. Und wer das Fritz-Zockerteam schlagen möchte, füllt den Fritz-Zockerteam-Herausforderungszettel aus. Den Fritz-Zockerteam-Herausforderungszettel gibt's an der Fritz-Hotline. 0331 für Potsdam, 70 97 110 und unter www.fritzdi.fussball.de im Freien und im Radio.
Auf Fritz 20 Minuten noch Chaosradio heute Abend, letzter Mittwoch im Monat mit Frank Harald und Max im Studio. Thema Stromverbrauch von Unterhaltungselektronik. Und am Telefon ist der Michael aus Bayern zugeschaltet. Hallo Michael.
Hallo. Also ich hab mir mal überlegt, wie schaut es eigentlich aus mit Wiederverkaufswert von Rechnern und Wiederverwendbarkeit. Da war es ja eigentlich so in den letzten Jahren, so Pentium 1, Pentium 2, das konnte man noch schöner als Server weiterverwenden, war nicht besonders laut, irgendwie ein, zwei Lüfter oder so. Und eigentlich der Stromverbrauch hielt sich in Grenzen. Jetzt schaut es allerdings so aus, in den nächsten Jahren stehen wir irgendwie vor einer Masse von Pentium-4-Rechnern, Atlauns, die irgendwie 100, 200 Watt verbrauchen und keine Ahnung dröhnende Lüfter. Also das sehe ich echt ein großes Problem.
Das mag wohl so sein, ja. Die Frage ist halt, wie die Entwicklung weitergeht. Wenn dann sozusagen die Nachfolgegeneration in drei, vier Jahren, wenn es dann gar keine Rechner mehr gibt, die unter 500, 600 Watt brauchen, weil sie alle irgendwie noch viel mehr Strom verbrauchen, dann werden die Leute immer noch sagen, ach ist ja schön, wir haben noch diese alten, diese alten Pentium-4, die brauchen ja nur 200 Watt, können wir uns darüber freuen. Das wäre sozusagen einfach extrapoliert, was bisher passiert ist im Laufe der Zeit, ob sich das jetzt umkehrt, das wäre natürlich schön. Und wenn sich es umkehrt, dann wird man natürlich irgendwie diese alten Kisten, diese Stromfresser, wahrscheinlich kaum mehr irgendwie an den Mann bringen.
Genau, also...
So wie alte Kühlschränke...
.vergleich, da wurde mal irgendwie, wenn man auf Heise, wurde eine Herdplatte, ein Uranbrennstab und ein Pentium-4 verglichen bei der Abwärme pro Quadratzentimeter. Die Herdplatte kam auf schlappe 8 Watt pro Quadratzentimeter. Der Uranbrennstab auf immerhin 65 Watt pro Quadratzentimeter. Und der Pentium-4 hat natürlich gewonnen mit über 100 Watt pro Quadratzentimeter. Und es gibt einen irgendwie schon zu denken.
Ja, das ist erinnert habwichtig.
Ich weiß schon, warum ich meinen Uranbrennstab benutze.
Ja, was spielst du denn für Spiele mit deinem Uranbrennstab?
Die ganz gefährlichen.
Verstehe. Ja, wir haben noch eine Frage an dich. Und zwar, was schätzt du denn, dass die deutsche Wirtschaft insgesamt kostet mit den ganzen Standby-Funktionen der Geräte? Wie viel Geld in Euro geht da pro Jahr verloren durch die Standby-Funktionen?
Ich hab mal gehört, dass irgendwie zwei Atomkraftwerke sein sollen, jährlich, die man sich einsparen könnte. Also es geht auf jeden Fall in die Milliarden.
Du kriegst ja gar nicht so schlecht mit den zwei Atomkraftwerken. Ich hab halt von anderen kleineren Kraftwerken Zahlen gesehen, da geht's dann eher so 5-7 Kraftwerke. Und in Euro gefasst sind es 3, 5 Milliarden Euro jedes Jahr, die für Standby in Geräte ausgegeben werden.
Nicht schlecht.
Aber um keinen Pessimismus aufkommen zu lassen, das kurbelt natürlich alles die Wirtschaft an. Unser Atomkraftwerk muss auch überleben.
Na ja, das ist aber politisch nicht mehr korrekt mit der rot-grünen Bundesregierung.
Aber in China interessiert es ja keine, da lachen die Leute darüber.
Moment, ich mach das nochmal neu. Das Wasserkraftwerk muss ja auch überleben.
Der Staudamm, genau.
Richtig. Ja, ähm, vielleicht an der Stelle noch erwähnenswert, weil wir gerade bei Wasserkraft sind. Es gibt auch eine Kampagne, das Atomstromfreie Internet. Das ist eine Kampagne der Greenpeace Energy AG. Das ist eine Genossenschaft, die als Stromanbieter aufzügt, wo man also grünen Strom kaufen kann. Und da gibt es dann auch ein entsprechendes Logo. Und wenn man also seinen Webserver mit Strom von Greenpeace Energy betreibt, dann kann man sich ein Logo auf die Webseite machen, dass also die Seite mit atomstromfreien Internet betrieben wird.
Hm, auch sehr beliebt in Mails unten als Futter. Diese Mail wurde mit atomstromfreien...
Wir haben ja vorhin über Wirkungsgrade gesprochen. Es gibt ja jetzt auch diese Entwicklung, Treibstoff, so kleine Treibstofftanks für Notebooks zu entwickeln. Das ist auch schon relativ weit. Die sind ziemlich effizient, kann das sein?
Batterien ist übrigens auch noch so eine ganze Akkugeschichte, ist auch noch mal ein weiter Themenbereich. Da sind wir aber zum Glück auf dem richtigen Weg. Das ist diese Lithium-Ionen-Akkus, die jetzt eigentlich fast nur noch, ja eigentlich nur noch sind in Notebooks. Die sind schon mal deutlich weniger umweltschädlich als das alte Nickel-Catmium und Nickel-Metallhydrit. Da sind wir schon mal auf einem ganz guten Weg und sie sind als Nebeneffekt dann auch noch viel effizienter und speichern mehr Strom.
Treibstoff, Brennstoffzellen oder so.
Ja, das mit den Brennstoffzellen ist ja zur Zeit ein ziemlicher Hype, ziemlich in Entwicklung, da wird auch irgendwie jedes Jahr wird neu was versprochen und kommt dann doch nicht. Es ist anscheinend noch so, dass irgendwie die Wirkungsgrade noch nicht allzu hoch sind. Also die müssen diesen Brennstoff, das ist dann irgendwie meistens Methanol oder so, ist auch sehr stark verdünnt mit Wasser, weil anders funktioniert das gar nicht bis jetzt.
Ja, also ich meine, wir haben ja auch schon seit Jahren gehört vom Auto mit Brennstoffzellen und so weiter. Was man bei der ganzen Sache auch immer nicht vergessen darf, ist, also irgendwie muss ja die Grundlage für diese Brennstoffzelle auch irgendwo herkommen, also der Energieträger. Wenn das jetzt Methanol ist, gut, das kann man jetzt unterschiedlich gewinnen. Schön kann man das immer bei den Wasserstoff-Sachen irgendwie sich vor Augen führen. Wenn ich jetzt irgendwo ein Wasserstoff-Auto oder irgendwas derartiges habe, dann muss der Wasserstoff ja auch irgendwo herkommen und wenn ich den Wasserstoff erzeuge, beispielsweise durch Elektrolyse aus Wasser, dann muss ich da Energie reinstecken und wenn ich die Energie wieder in dem konventionellen Kraftwerk gewinne, welches selbst schon nur einen Wirkungsgrad von unter 50 Prozent hat, dann kann es mit meinem insgesamten Systemwirkungsgrad auch nicht sonderlich hoch sein.
Der meiste Wasserstoff, der wird heutzutage eigentlich aus Erdgas hergestellt, also eigentlich ist die Diskussion ziemlich für die Katz.
Ja, das ist richtig. Es ist halt die Frage, wie lange das geht. Erdgasvorkommen sind ja auch, da gibt es immer wieder schöne Prognosen und da kann man dann wieder richtig pessimistisch werden.
Ich warte ja auf dieses Ding, das entwickeln sie am MIT. Da wird der komplette Verbundstoff zum Beispiel von Notebooks aus einem Plastik und gemischt mit Spinatderivat gemacht und das wird dann durch Fotosynthese an der Strom gewonnen und das finde ich sehr spannend. Also dass quasi das Gehäuse aus festem Spinat ist und komplett Fotosynthese-reaktiv ist.
Sag mal, hast du das am ersten April gelesen, der war doch noch gar nicht.
Naja, also ich fand es toll. Ich würde es mir wünschen und wenn man zwischendurch Hunger hat, hat man auch irgendwie was zum Knabbern. Und der Mike noch aus Zossen. Morgen.
Morgen, ich habe eigentlich mal eine generelle Frage, also ich mache mit dem PC so ziemlich alles. Also ich höre da Radio drauf, ist übrigens echt schön zu hören, wie groß eigentlich immer noch diese Verzögung ist. Ich gucke Fernseh drauf und habe eigentlich mal eine Frage, ist der Stromverbrauch bei einem Fernseh höher, als wenn ich über einen PC Fernseh gucken würde?
Nee, geringer.
Ist geringer.
In aller Regel.
Kommt natürlich auch den Fernseher drauf an, aber du siehst es ja schon am Typenschild, was der Fernseher hinten verbraucht, was da maximal angegeben ist. Und was du jetzt so gehört hast, was so PCs verbrauchen.
Also bei den Fernsehern ist es halt auch so, dass die eigentlich konstant Strom verbrauchen. Das heißt, wenn auf dem Fernseher irgendwie 80 oder 100 Watt drauf steht, dann ist das auch tatsächlich die Leistung, die der aufnimmt. Hingegen beim Computer, diese Angabe vom Netzteil und so weiter, das ist immer nur das Maximale, was irgendwie, wenn alles gleichzeitig benutzt wird und jede Komponente unter Volltast ist. Aber in der Regel, wenn man so einen typischen Fernseher sich ansieht, dann braucht er weniger Strom als ein PC mit Monitor zusammen.
Heut noch zwei Sachen, gerade diese Geschichte mit dem Spinat, das aus Photosynthese gewonnen wird, das ist für eine Ladenparty nicht ganz so toll, weil die Leute sind ja da immer doch eher darauf bedacht, irgendwie im Dunkeln zu sitzen.
Na ja, aber Photosynthese geht mit UV-Licht und UV-Lampen sind da ja auch sehr beliebt.
Kaufst du dir einfach so eine UV-Licht-abstrahlende Jacke?
Das sind dann die Pflanzenlampen nicht mehr so verdächtig daheim.
Das wäre natürlich auch die Idee, das wäre ja eine Art Zoonboob-Ilee, dass man sich dann so ein paar Lichtstoffkartonen in den Rechner baut und dann irgendwie seinen eigenen Strom gewinnt.
Oder man überredet seine Kumpels auf der LAN-Party dazu, das da einzubauen und bezieht dann durch die Kumpels den Strom und die checken das gar nicht.
Also wir selber veranstalten ja auch LAN-Partys, weil ja davon schon mal die Sache kam von einem Kumpel, der mit seinen Kumpels so ein LAN-Party gemacht hat mit zwölf Leuten. Ich kenne den von unten, ich bin zwar nicht der Strommensch, ich habe da keine Ahnung von, aber wenn ich immer sehe, was wir so an Kabel austeilen und Verteiler von 64 Ampere runter auf 16, das ist aber schon ziemlich gigantisch.
Ihr könnt ja immer so Laufräder aufstellen, wo die Leute ihren Strom selber erzeugen müssen.
Ja, das ist aber doof, dass die dann immer eine Weile so schnell karo sind.
Ja, vor allem wird es keiner mit einem Laufrad schaffen, tatsächlich irgendwie seinen Rechner am Laufen zu halten. Das ist ein großes Problem.
Du, wenn einer seinen 3D-Shooter spielen will, da ist einiges drin, soll ich dir sagen.
Muss er erstmal einen Tag lang im Laufrad laufen, um aufzuladen und dann kann er zwei Stunden spielen.
Ja, wie diese Drehradios.
Ja, da bekommt das Wort Realität auch wieder eine ganz neue Bedeutung, wenn man in der Hochschule spielt und durch die mehr brennen muss. Das war's eigentlich auch schon von mir, ja.
Okay, danke für den Anruf.
Super. Dann vielleicht noch mal eine ganz kurze Einladung von unseren Leuten, die noch im Berliner Club sitzen, gebeten worden. Wir haben donnerstags immer einen offenen Club, das ist der sogenannte Club des Cordia in Berlin in der Marienstraße 11. Und das ist so ein offener Abend, da passiert immer nicht so furchtbar viel, da sitzen die Leute nett beisammen, quatschen ein bisschen, unterhalten sich und es ist eine gute Gelegenheit für Leute, die jetzt den Club einfach mal kennenlernen wollen, einfach mal vorbeizukommen.
Strom gibt's for free.
Genau, Strom gibt's for free, Internet haben wir auch.
Wir haben sogar Nachtstrom.
Wir haben sogar Nachtstrom, genau, wir haben ungeschaltet. Das heißt ab 22 Uhr haben wir jetzt einen besonders günstigen Nachtstrom.
Wenn die wüssten, wem die das verkauft haben, den Nachtstrom.
Genau, ansonsten unsere Homepage ist chaosradio.ccc.de, also ohne www.daforein von chaosradio.ccc.de. Wenn ihr irgendwelche Nachfragen, Sachen habt, dann schickt ihr eine Mail an chaosradio.ccc.de. Und ich möchte noch mal auf die Wikiseite, in Wikipedia hinweisen, da haben wir eine Mitmachs-Seite, die ist verlinkt von unserer Homepage, von der chaosradio.ccc.de-Seite. Und da könnt ihr ja selber auch noch Sachen, Fragen einstellen, Antworten einstellen. Das ist eine ganz schöne Dynamik, da hat sich jetzt im Laufe der Sendung schon jede Menge getan. Und nochmal vielen Dank an alle, die da mitgemacht haben. Und wir werden da auch sicherlich noch im Nachlauf der Sendung ein bisschen was zu schreiben. Und habt Spaß mit der Materialsammlung, die wir da schon mal eingestellt haben.
Vielleicht an der Stelle auch noch am Abschluss die Anmerkung, dass das Thema Energieverbrauch von Computern tatsächlich ein Thema ist, das wir aufgegriffen haben aus der Themenvorschlag-Seite, aus dem Wiki in der Wikipedia.
Vorbildlich abgelaufen. Also all das am heutigen Abend und auch in der Vorbereitung. Wir verabschieden uns wirklich mit Freude, hat Spaß gemacht und ich hätte die Resonanz auch nicht so krass erwartet. Geiles Thema. Weiter macht jetzt Martin Petersdorf hier im Night Flight mit schicker Musik.